Hey, Wolfgang.
Hallo, Stefan.
Sag mal, welche Dating Apps nutzt du so?
Ich hab hier Instagram. Wir klären den Scherz gleich auf. Als ich mich bei Instagram anmeldete, sagte mir eine gute Freundin, das sei ja so die vornehme Variante von irgendwelchen Dating Apps. Und das fand ich ganz amüsant, ist aber sofort einleuchtend natürlich, weil man dort mit Bild vertreten ist. Diese Storys ermöglichen so eine unverfängliche Interaktion. Also man kann einfach mal sagen, ach ja, schönes Foto oder da war ich auch mal. Das ist jetzt was anderes, wie wenn man sagt, ich schreib da jetzt mal eine DM bei Twitter oder so. Das heißt, das ermöglicht einen niedrigschwelligen Einstieg in eine Konversation. Und von daher leuchtet mir das ja ein, dass Instagram funktioniert. Man hat zugleich auch so ein bisschen schon vom Alltag, vielleicht auch die Interessen, die wichtig sind für alles Weitere. Keine Ahnung, mir sagte dann aber auch eine bekannte LinkedIn, würde genutzt werden, für Sexpartys zu organisieren, was mich dann auch wiederum sehr verwundert hat. Aber gut, man lernt nie aus.
Wundert mich alles gar nicht, denn, und da will ich nur kurz anmerken, ich bin ja auch ein getrennt erziehender Vater. Ich wollte auch gestern nochmal im Fernsehpodcast die Ausgabe 100 nutzen, um da ein paar Anmerkungen zu machen, wie ich ab sofort Bücher lese wie das heutige, nämlich anders. Und ja, Instagram als Dating App, muss ich sagen, verstehe ich sofort, denn nichts ist schlimmer, als wenn im Grunde alles schon durch, ah ja, du schreibst hier rüber, na dann wissen wir ja alle, worum es geht. Nee, Instagram ist halt einfach eine offene Plattform für alles. Und was das für eine Anmache ist, wenn man in DM slidet und ob es überhaupt eine Anmache ist, das ist eben noch unklar. Und dadurch gewinnt es überhaupt erst den entsprechenden Wert und das entsprechende Gefühl, würde ich sagen. Deswegen glaube ich sofort, dass Instagram und LinkedIn dafür gut genutzt wird, um nicht zu sagen, von Herstellerseite auch aus Missbraucht, wobei die ja diesen Missbrauch wieder wahrscheinlich besonders dulden, wenn nicht sogar fördern, würde mich nicht wundern. Und bei LinkedIn ein paar Leute sitzen, die das nochmal besonders forcieren irgendwie, dass diese App natürlich auch so genutzt wird. Denn der Arbeitsplatz, der Arbeitsplatz, nirgendwo gibt es einen größeren Heiratsmarkt, denn Menschen müssen sich ja auch begegnen irgendwie. Es lohnt sich ja nicht, nur im Internet abzuhängen. Kommt mir auch nichts bei.
Und die Kommunikation gleich über etwas, was beide kennen, ist auch wichtig, dass sie sonst oft gefunden werden. Das fällt mir jetzt nicht schwer, wenn man über Kultur oder sonst was redet, aber wenn man es dann nicht so präsent hat, also der Small Talk ist ja für viele Leute eine Zumutung, für mich auch. Und dann kann das, glaube ich, für viele Leute sehr hilfreich sein, wenn man sagt, ach ja, bei dem Unternehmen habe ich auch schon gearbeitet. Ich bin jetzt aber bei der BASF und dann kann die Kommunikation losgehen.
Ja, ja, genau. Es ist was los im Internet, sagen wir es mal so. Und nicht ohne Grund, halt deswegen Alfie Bown. Das muss ich echt noch mal nachgucken. Bauen, ja? Ohne?
Ja, ohne, ja.
Okay, also Alfie Bown. Ist es ein Mann oder eine Frau? Es ist ein Mann, ne?
Es ist ein Mann.
Bei Twitter zu finden und ist auch ganz interessant ihm zu folgen.
Relativ jung, hat relativ viele Bücher so zum Thema irgendwie geschrieben. Kreuz und Quer, also jemand, der sich auskennt.
Über Gamification, über Computerspiele. Ich hab eines gelesen, wo er zeigt, wie die Computerspiele organisiert sind, was da möglich ist, dass Ludische da so eine Theorie entwickelt.
Genau. Und bevor wir inhaltlich einsteigen, ich habe ja gedacht, du hast es relativ gern gelesen, denn es kommen ja recht viele deutsche Denker drin vor. Also jetzt aus meiner Richtung georg Simmel, Max Weber, Niklas Luhmann. Alle finden ihre kurze Erwähnung aus deiner Richtung auch. Angefangen bei Freud natürlich und das ganze Universum. Aber du hast vorhin zu mir gemeint...
Ich war nicht so begeistert...
.grässlich sogar.
Ich fand es bislang wirklich grässlich, auch wenn da die klingenden Namen vorkommen. Julia Christevas, Lavoj Zizek, Lacan, Alain Badiou. Natürlich kommen sie alle vor, aber sie kommen mir fast ein bisschen zu viel vor. Und ich habe bei diesem Autor mitunter den Verdacht, es gibt einen Hang, einen Drang zur Theoretisierung, wo sie manchmal gar nicht von Nöten wäre. Das Buch ist da sehr stark, wo es einfach mal eine neue App beschreibt und sagt, was die da eigentlich macht. Und dann kommt aber sofort wieder ein Bezug zu, ist das nicht so ähnlich wie der Begriff von De Fèvre? Und ist das nicht aber eigentlich wieder die Begehrenstruktur, die uns Lacan sagt, und führt das nicht da und dort zu? Das ist natürlich nah an dem vielleicht, was man bei Zizek finden kann, aber bei Zizek habe ich dann doch immer noch bei all diesen Assoziationsketten diesen großen Aha-Moment, dass er es dann plötzlich auf den Kopf stellt und sagt, aber so könnte es sein. Und dass ich damit eine eigene Theorie wieder an die Hand bekomme, die fehlt mir hier. Hier sind wir sehr stark in der Paraphrase drin. Und ich habe auch den Verdacht, wenn man in diesen poststrukturalistischen Theorien nicht so drin ist, wird man da bei zumindest einigen Abschnitten Mühe haben. Und das ist blöde, weil der Autor sich eigentlich sehr viel dadurch selbst verstellt, wo er viel konkreter sein könnte. Und das sagt jetzt nicht, dass ich das Buch verdamme in Bausch und Bogen, aber ich finde es tatsächlich mitunter sehr gesucht und sehr auf eine Theorie ausgelegt oder auf Theorie ausgelegt, die aber dann eigentlich nicht geleistet wird. Und das hat mich ein bisschen abgeschreckt oder zunehmend genervt.
Das stimmt, verstehe ich. Es hat eine gewisse Ruhelosigkeit. Wir kennen die Geruhsamkeit, die darauf basieren kann, wenn man sich wie ein Anfänger bei den beiden Davids, der eine Grabber, 700 Seiten Zeit nimmt und dann so richtig all in in die, und das ist übrigens die App aus China, da geht man so ganz ethnographisch durch, was kann man da lernen und dann die Theoriearbeit nachliefert. Nicht nur sagt der Luhmann, der hat ja auch darüber geschrieben, dass Liebe ein von außen externalisiertes Gefühl dann irgendwie ist, was auch immer, sondern ja, da hätte man durchaus mehr zu sagen können. Aber diese ethnografischen Anlagen, ja, so ein bisschen sind sie ja drin. Gleich als allererstes werden wir über den Tencent App Store aufgeklärt, also den weltweit größten Marktplatz für alles irgendwie digitale. Und da gibt es Halli-Cinogenic Commodities. Also es ist auch eigene Wortschöpfung überall dabei. Und natürlich Virtual Reality Relationship Simulators, also die uns das ist irgendwie immer verrückt. Man liest so Sachen aus China und denkt oder auch Japan. Nee, das machen die nicht so, oder? Die suchen sich nicht wirklich so eine virtuelle Freundin, die sie da nachts mit ihrer Brille besuchen. Komplett abgeschottet von der eigenen Welt, in der sie gerade leben und vom eigenen Körpergefühl kommt. Aber ja, scheint es alles zu geben, so wie man in Japan auch vor zehn Jahren schon natürlich eine Puppe mit am Tisch hatte, wenn man zu Abend aß und so. Das sind alles so Sachen, die kennt man hier nicht. Und in der Ansicht ist es besonders gut, solche Sachen noch mal zu lesen. Verheiratet mit Anime-Style-Fame-Bots. Solche Sachen. Also es geht relativ abstrus los. Und dann kommt es auf Grindr zu sprechen. Also die Plattform, die wie Tinder funktioniert, aber eben für nicht heterosexuelle Menschen. Mit der Verwunderung, das ist ganz interessant, dass sie von der Beijing Kunlun Tech, was auch immer Konsortium, Konzern aufgekauft werden sollte. Und dann Trump intervenierte. Und dann sieht man schon, ah es gab also einen großen kulturellen Einschlag, Systemstreit, Trump gegen den Rest der Welt, insbesondere gegen China. Und plötzlich hat Trump eine Homo-Porno-App verteidigt, was man ihm auch nicht zugetraut hätte.
Es ist keine Porno-App, es ist eine Dating-App.
Also eine Homo-Sex-App, sag ich das mal so.
Genau.
Was man als allerletztes von Trump auf diesem ich revolutioniere mal das Christentum in der Politik und so weiter vermutet hätte. Da sieht man schon, wie die Liebeswelt und die politische Sphäre da zusammen clashing. In der Hinsicht fand ich schon mal ein guter Einstieg insgesamt. Man hat was gelernt.
Bei Grindr ist ja interessant, dass das eine App war, die vor Tinder entwickelt wurde. Und dass das also eine App war für Schwule, die sich dort daten können. Und die Frage war dann, werden auf diese Weise nach rechts und links leiden oder oben und unten leiden, keine Ahnung. Und diese Verortung, dass man sehen kann, ach, da ist jemand nur noch 300 Meter entfernt, werden auf diese Weise sich auch Heterosexuelle vernetzen miteinander. Oder ist das nur, weil nun in der schwulen Kultur, gerade in der Subkultur solche Cruising Areas oder so in einer anderen Weise etabliert sind, wodurch es nicht leicht fällt, dass dann auch eine solche App dankbar aufgegriffen wird? Und die Antwort war natürlich, ja klar, machen die das auch und sagen, ah, endlich habe ich auch mal sowas, dass ich auf ganz praktische, fast friktionsfreie Weise mir Sex organisieren kann. Also klar, man kann über solche Apps auch die große Liebe finden, aber die sind schon sehr stark darauf ausgelegt, Tinder wie auch Grindr zu sagen, naja, ich habe jetzt auch noch zwei Stunden Zeit und schau her, ich habe auch gut trainiert.
Genau, dieses Argument macht er dann vor allem für Tinder. Da wird Sex mal so richtig barkkonform und effizient erreichbar. Es wird einfach so in den Tagesablauf eingebunden, dass der Arbeitgeber denkt, cool, da kommt er auf seine Kosten und ist trotzdem pünktlich bei der Arbeit, weil diese ganzen Sachen, die erotischerweise vorher und nachher laufen, die finden einfach gar nicht statt, sondern das ist so ein richtig marktkonformes Beziehungsleben, das man dann führt. Und in der Hinsicht nicht nur in China, sondern auch in Amerika hat ja das alles Konjunktur match.com. Das wusste ich auch nicht, dass sie mittlerweile alles aufgekauft haben. Also der ganze Datingmarkt gehört irgendwie zu match.com. Und dieser Graben zwischen Spielen und Liebe, Games and Love und Simulation und Realität, der schließt sich so langsam. Also das geht so in Richtung deiner Frage. Wer nimmt hier eigentlich teil und für wen? Ganz explizit, dem Buch wird thematisiert, wir sind ja eigentlich alle nur noch in so eine Maschine verliebt. Dann die Menschen dahinter kennenzulernen, ist ja noch mal was anderes, als die ganze Zeit so Maschinen vermittelt, wo man selber so ein bisschen zur Maschine wird und sich dann alle fragen, werde ich gerade programmiert oder nutze ich noch ein Programm, wo das so zweigleisig abläuft. Und da ist das Buch ja ganz stark am Anfang, finde ich. Dating und Porno-Plattformen, die also immer mehr bis hin zu komplett unser Liebesleben organisieren. Also für mich ist das völlig undenkbar, diese Art der Apps. Klar, ich kenne sie soweit, aber wenn ich das hier so lese, wie all in da manche Menschen gehen, das ist ja wirklich erstaunlich. Und dennoch fühle ich auch, dass das nicht falsch formuliert ist, wenn er sagt, das sind wahrscheinlich die mächtigsten, weil die so tief in unsere intimsten und ultimativsten Wünsche nicht nur einsteigen, sie kennenlernen, sondern den wirklich auch mitsteuern, indem sie so ein Angebot schaffen. Oder nur so eine Sehnsucht nach etwas, immer wieder so am Köcheln halten. Also in der Hinsicht auch wahnsinnig gefährlich eigentlich. Dieses Element der Gefahr hätte da, also fehlte mir so ein bisschen, dass man das vielleicht nochmal noch deutlicher macht, was das so für die eigene individuelle Lebensgestaltung irgendwie bedeuten kann. Und es geht in diesem Falle eben nicht nur darum, Aufmerksamkeit und Werbeökonomie zu betreiben, sondern um das Potenzial soziale Leben gänzlich neu zu organisieren. Angefangen bei diesen ganz intimen Momenten, in die man da so richtig all in reingeht und mit so einem Programm einfach Code is Law und so, einfach mal alltags strukturiert. Und dann von da aus ist natürlich das Argument nicht weit, um dann auch ausführlich über Politik zu sprechen. Also dieser Bogenschlag gefiel mir wirklich ziemlich gut.
Ich finde auch, dass der Einstieg absolut gelungen ist und dann hätte er auf manche poststrukturalistischen Theorien zum Begehren eher ein bisschen verzichten können, um es klarer zu machen. Denn wir haben in der letzten Ausgabe über digitale Identität gesprochen und du hast noch mal vorgestellt, wie war das eigentlich? Wann bekam man eigentlich einen Pass? Wann wurde man der Staatsbürger? Wann bekam man da die Identität? Und das organisiert ja unglaublich viel. Das organisiert zum Beispiel so etwas wie das Schicksal, was wir von Janek eben im Teaser geschildert bekommen haben, dass da jemand kommt aus einem afrikanischen Land und hier keine Arbeitsstelle bekommt, keine Ausbildungsstelle, vielleicht wieder abgeschoben wird. Also der Pass organisiert wahnsinnig viel. Und die Frage ist jetzt, was wird eigentlich organisiert dadurch, dass man eine Struktur erschafft, wo Menschen sich zum Beispiel kennenlernen, wo sie sich zum Sex verabreden oder wo sie Sex konsumieren können, den andere anbieten in Form von Pornofilmen oder Life Sex oder was auch immer. Und ich glaube, dass man hier erst mal ganz deutlich machen muss, dass Ideologie oft über diese kleinen Schritte und über Technik funktioniert. Also Ideologie meint nicht immer mächtiger, Herrischer steht da und verkündet Propaganda, wie wir das da manchmal von Chi beobachten können und dann auch dankbar abspielen in Clips, sondern es ist so, dass wir gerade bei diesen inkrementellen Veränderungen eine Veränderung von Subjekten herstellen, beziehungsweise dass bestimmte Subjekte erst so produziert werden. Was meine ich damit? Also Leute, die dann produziert werden und so kodiert werden, dass sie tatsächlich sagen das erste, was ich ja wissen muss, ob ich mit jemanden mich connecte, ist, wie sind die Geschlechtsteile? Das ist eine neue Kodierung, die dann vorgenommen wird. Also etwas, was man jetzt in Konstellationen früher in Kennenlernprozessen sehr viel später erfahren hat, wo Ausrichtungen auf anderes lagen, ist zum Beispiel das jetzt eine Neuausrichtung. Oder der gesellschaftliche Status. Es kommt ja dann sehr viel später noch, geht es da um eine Dating App, die wirklich mit so einem Punktsystem arbeitet, aus dem man dann erschließen kann, okay, das ist jemand mit einem offenbar hohen Monatseinkommen und ich will ja jemanden daten mit einem hohen Monatseinkommen. Und diese Strukturierung, die da stattfindet, ist natürlich nicht eine, die jetzt erst durch die Digitalität entsteht, sondern es entsteht jetzt eine andere Struktur. Denn natürlich ist auch unser Datingverhalten, wenn wir es jetzt ganz analog machen, eines, das mit Exklusionen arbeitet und das auch mit Dingen arbeitet, die schon vorhergesehen sind. Also es ist natürlich klar, wenn man jetzt auf die Suche geht, dann würde man in Bars und Restaurants oder Kulturveranstaltungen gehen, wo man glaubt, auf Gleichgesinnte zu treffen oder wo man sagt, das ist ein Status, der mir hilft, der mir irgendwie zu Passe kommt. Also sicherlich wäre es jetzt sehr eigenartig, wenn jemand wie ich in, weiß ich nicht, wohin gehen würde, an Imbissbuden suchen würde.
Ja, also da kommen wir auch heute noch häufiger drauf zurück. Milieus aufzubrechen, über Milieu glänzen hinweg und so weiter. Das ist ja hier auch eins dieser großen Themen. In der Politik sehen wir, wie sich die Milieus eben nicht mehr vermischen. Und deswegen auch Unverständnis über das jeweils andere Milieu. Und das ist eben in China ganz knallhart in die Dating Apps rein programmiert. Da sollen gefälligst keine Bande geschlossen werden, die vielleicht sogar noch politisch irgendwie gemeinsam aufmüpfig werden. Nicht in Schicksalsgemeinschaften, sondern da wird erstmal segmentiert und dann soll man seine Wünsche innerhalb dieser sozialen Segmente ausprägen. Und da fand ich, es waren doch gute Hinweise am Anfang im Buch, nochmal klar zu unterscheiden, ja wenn wir über Dating Apps reden geht es um am Ende wollen die Leute Sex, Männer wie Frauen. Aber bevor es dazu kommt, müssen Wünsche ausgebildet werden, Desires. Und das wird ja nochmal klar unterschieden, um dann auch das Argument zu machen, diese Transformation der Wünsche, also nicht das konkrete Ausleben oder so, sondern schon das, was im Kopf desjenigen stattfindet. Diese Transformation der Wünsche ist politisch. Also um da schon einzuhaken und zu sagen, also hier werden so kockentiefe Anker geworfen, von irgend wem auch immer. Im Silicon Valley ist die Politik ja auch nicht fern, das ist ja nur China, wir wissen ja was die NSA da so vor hat und auch tut dank Snowden. Und diese Transformation der Wünsche ist politisch. Wir haben Vorstellungen und Wünsche und die, und dann kommt das große kulturelle Argument, waren schon immer fremdgesteuert. Dann werden genannt, die ganzen Institutionen, die Kunst, der Kulturbetrieb und so weiter. Und neu ist jetzt diese besonders wichtige Rolle der Technologie. Und da fällt hier ein ganz wichtiger Satz, denn bei der Zielsetzung des Buches geht es darum, ja wir passen uns diesen Gegebenheiten immer wahnsinnig schnell an. Jeder hat ein Smartphone, jeder der es braucht nutzt solche Apps. Und jetzt geht es ihm darum, Taking control of our new desires. Er ist also nicht so nostalgisch angelegt und sagt, es war besser, wie es vorher war, als wir uns zum Tanztee trafen, statt bei Tinder. Sondern sagt, ne Tinder ist jetzt schon da und wir haben neue Wünsche und wir müssen auch über diese neuen Wünsche reden. Und ja früher gab es auch einen Tanztee. Aber wir wollen jetzt nicht die Rolle rückwärts machen, nur weil wir feststellen, die Apps sind so ein bisschen überbordend und so weiter. Sondern dann lieber Aufklärung über die neuen Leidenschaften, die wir ausprägen, als da irgendwie nostalgisch an die Sache ranzugehen. Und das finde ich einen erstaunlich wenig technokritischen Ansatz, der hier irgendwie gut tut, statt so eine deutsche Diskussion zu führen.
Das wundert mich, dass du das jetzt gut findest. Ich war sofort, als ich das las, sicher, du wirst es ablehnen. Denn du bist ja ein Fan, ist vielleicht zu viel gesagt, aber ein Bewunderer der Arbeiten von Manfred Spitzer. Und Manfred Spitzer mit Büchern wie Digitale Demenz oder Einsamkeit ist das jemand, der sagt, geht hinaus, seid nicht nur da. Und die Frage, die ich mir stelle und die sich durch die ganze Lektüre gezogen hat, ist eigentlich, ja, ich sehe das ganz klar, dass diese Plattformen uns codieren, Subjekte hervorbringen. Es heißt ja schon ziemlich am Anfang, in that sense, Grindr was augmented reality before augmented reality. Ja, dass also unsere Realität durch eine solche App strukturiert wird. Aber was muss man denn eigentlich für Prämissen mitgehen, wenn man dieser nicht so technokritischen Position folgt? Erst einmal eine gewisse fatalistische Haltung, was die Digitalisierung anbelangt. Unsere Beziehungen, unser Sex wird auf jeden Fall digital organisiert werden. Wo ich fragen würde, muss das wirklich so sein? Sagen nicht uns jetzt gerade, wo wir so plädiert haben, geht in die Konzerte, geht mal ins Restaurant, dass die unmittelbaren Begegnungen, die nicht digital sind, wo wir alle unsere Smartphones vergessen haben oder zumindest in der Tasche lassen, dass die etwas sind, wo sich vielleicht auch das Digitale unglaublich relativiert. Nicht nur in dem Sinn, dass man sagt, ich habe einen Shitstorm auf Twitter, ist halt auch nur auf Twitter, sondern auch, dass man sagt, naja, das ist irgendwie ein Insta-Profil, aber der Mensch dahinter ist eigentlich das Interessante oder viel interessanter als das perfekte Bild. Und dann stellt sich auch die Frage, wer programmiert das Ganze? Also hier geht es jetzt darum, eine progressive Programmierung eigentlich herzustellen, was ich erst einmal für wichtig empfinde. Und ich würde auch sagen, man muss programmieren, generell viel stärker politisieren. Aber es gibt ja auch immer noch das, dass man als Mensch nicht nur diesen Programmen unterworfen ist, denn du hast es ja gerade selbst so im Nebensatz fallen lassen. Ja, ich kenne natürlich diese Apps, aber ich bin da ja nicht. Oder selbst wenn du dich jetzt einmal anmelden würdest, glaube ich, würde das nicht gleich dazu führen, dass du jetzt zu einem Tinder Subjekt wirst, sondern du würdest vielleicht das dreimal machen und sagen, na ja, aber eigentlich ist doch vielleicht vernünftiger, mal zum Sport zu gehen und gucken, ob man da jemanden kennenlernt.
Also da stecken ganz viele Fragen drin und ich versuche jetzt mal zu beantworten. Denn ja, ich finde es total sympathisch und wichtig, dass ihr jemand die technische Realität anerkennt, wie sie ist und sich nicht einfach die Rolle rückwärts, wo es mal anders war, wo man sich noch daran erinnert und so weiter, wünscht. Denn die Technik ist ja in der Welt. Das heißt zum einen, ich kann für mich ganz individuell entscheiden, und das habe ich auch, Anwarnungen sozialer jeglicher Art finden bei mir, soweit es geht, analog statt. Das Digitale kann dann gerne dazutreten, um das, was analog sowieso stattfindet, noch zu unterstützen. Und da ist die Technik einfach meisterhaft ein Gottessegen. Die Anwarnung finde ich immer noch ein bisschen schwierig.
Wir wollen keine Briefe mehr schreiben.
Ja, genau.
Nur bei ganz, also ja, aber stell dir mal vor, du müsstest jetzt Dates über Briefe organisieren. Wird man sagen, na so ein Moment, das sind zwei Tage nochmal und naja, klappt schon nicht mehr.
Sobald die soziale Landkarte gestaltet ist, schreibe ich Nachrichten so viel wie geht. Aber halt erst, wenn die soziale Landkarte entsprechend gestaltet ist. Nicht im Vorfeld dieses Bombardieren ins Nichts hinein, wo ich wirklich mehr mit einer Maschine kommuniziere als mit Personen. Das heißt, ich lese Manfred Spitzer, ich warte ja immer noch auf sein Buch, Grün erleben oder wie es heißt, Natur erleben. Und ich gehe auch so schon in den Wald einfach anders als du. Zum Beispiel, ich bin sehr viel im Wald und das ist auch alles wichtig. Aber, und das ist ein ganz wichtiges Argument, die Gesellschaft ist entgegen aller individuellen Ausprägungen und da ist jeder für sich selber irgendwie verantwortlich und führt auch sein eigenes und anderes Leben. Die Gesellschaft ist aber so strukturiert, wie sie nun mal strukturiert ist. Und wir leben nicht mehr in dieser analogen Zeitungswelt und so weiter. Sondern wenn auf Twitter irgendwas ist, muss ich das nicht lesen. Es hat trotzdem Effekte auf meine Lebenswelt, weil nämlich alle anderen so tun, als würden alle Twitter lesen. Und plötzlich liest mir Spiegel online die ganze Zeit vor, was auf Twitter passiert und abends in den Tagesthemen auch nochmal und so weiter. Also die Welt ist da einfach entsprechend umgebaut, auch wenn ich sie selbst anders lebe. Und da gibt es nun mal kein Zurück. Und deswegen finde ich es super wichtig, dass wir haben es ja hier nicht mit einem Therapeuten zu tun, der speziell auf meine Lebensphase ein politisches Argument macht. Sondern der sich einfach mit Gesellschaft auseinandersetzt, die nun mal ist, wie sie ist. Und da finde ich es super wichtig, dass man einfach anerkennt, Twitter ist da und Tinder ist da. Und es hat alles seine Rolle und Funktion. Wie der Einzelne sich dazu verhält, kann ein bisschen ignoriert werden.
Ich möchte da widersprechen. Es stimmt natürlich, dass es nicht die Aufgabe ist, jetzt für jeden da eine Gebrauchsanweisung fürs Leben zu schreiben. Wie soll das auch gehen? Nur, ist es ja so, dass vielleicht eine gewisse Distanz zu irgendwelchen Dating Apps oder auch zu Twitter, vielleicht daher rührt ja oder die kann erst ausgebildet werden, wenn man eine Gegenwelt sich aufgetan hat. Das heißt, was hier mir fehlt in diesem Buch ist, dass man auch sagen kann, man ist vielleicht davor gefeit, sich so sehr den Algorithmen und ihrer Logik hinzugeben, diese algorithmischen Gewalt ausgesetzt zu sein, wenn man die anderen Erfahrungen macht. Es war doch sehr schön auch zu hören, als wir von dieser Ansprache da hatten, von dem Amazon-Gewerkschafter Chris Smalls, der sagte, ja, diese Konzerne, die wissen irgendwie alles über uns, aber wir connecten. Wir sitzen zusammen, wir lachen, feiern, backen Brot zusammen. Und ich glaube, dass es schon auch darum gehen muss, neben der progressiven Programmierung, dass man aufzeigt, man kann auch eine Distanz zu diesen Plattformen entwickeln und zu all diesen Verführungen, diesen Begehrensanreizen, wenn man eine Welt auch außerhalb dieser Welt sich schafft. Und das wäre eine analoge und das meint aber jetzt nicht bei mir eine Nostalgie, dass ich sage, und deswegen machen wir jetzt wieder Tanz-Tees, sondern ich würde sagen, es gibt auch die Möglichkeit, gerade das Digitale zu nutzen, um dann schnell analoge Begegnungen zum Beispiel herzustellen. Oder um zu sagen, ja, ich kläre darüber auf, wie diese Plattformen funktionieren und versuche dadurch eine Distanzierung herzustellen. Ich bin aber doch ein bisschen skeptisch, wenn man so fatalistisch ist, dass man sagt, eigentlich sind wir jetzt digital, und wir können da nur noch mit einer progressiven Programmierung wegkommen. Denn da würde ich auch sagen, ist, wo die digitale Sphäre so vermachtet ist, die Chance relativ gering, dass da etwas passiert.
Ja, jetzt sind wir schon fast in so therapeutischen Thematisierungen.
Ich finde gar nicht, es ist doch definitiv so, dass man eine Haltung zum Digitalen ja nicht nur daraus entwickelt, was ich den ganzen Tag im Digitalen mache, sondern es resultiert ja auch eine gewisse Haltung dazu, wie ich sonst lebe, beziehungsweise um es deutlich zu machen, dass ich vielleicht ein bisschen anders Hollywoodfilme betrachte, liegt natürlich auch daran, dass ich sehr stark Romane, Literatur, im Allgemeinen Theaterstücke, Opernaufführungen genossen habe, rezipiert habe und dadurch relativiert sich in gewisser Weise auch das großartige Meisterwerk, das irgendein Hollywood Regisseur wieder hervorgebracht haben soll. Und ähnliches glaube ich auch stellt sich heraus, wenn man zwar ein Dating App nutzt, aber dann vielleicht doch auch zeigt, dass ein Miteinander anders aussehen kann, als einfach nur zu gucken, ob es irgendwie wie Stecker und Dose zusammenpasst.
Das verstehe ich. Also dieses Relativierungsargument finde ich glaube ich super wichtig, denn es ist ja wie der Alfie hier schreibt, am Ende bei dem Thema, um das es hier geht, das sind intime und ultimative Wünsche, die man da irgendwie zum Anklang bringt. Ich zeige es uns mal so. Man schlägt so einen Ton an und guckt mal, wer so resoniert, wo die Resonanzen und die Widerstände sind. Wenn man auf die Technologie, wie hier beschrieben, diese Dating Apps und so weiter, zugreift und man versteht das als Spiel, finde ich das gesund. Wenn man damit aber simulieren will, was man sich eigentlich analog wünscht, also wenn man eigentlich mit zu großen Erwartungen rangeht, dann wird es einfach psychologisch so ein bisschen brenzlig. Dann kann man sich da drin verlieren. Und dieses Buch handelt davon, wie sich ganz viele da drin verlieren und man gar nicht so genau weiß, wo drin eigentlich. Und dann haben wir es nicht nur mit Individuellen, sondern eben auch mit allgemeinen und entsprechend auch politischen Problemen zu tun. In der Hinsicht, ja vielleicht hätte das Buch, um auch bei dir besser Anklang finden zu können, beim Lesen schon noch mal so eine Gesprächsrunde einfach gebraucht, damit man das Problem noch mal genauer fasst, über das man dann einsam schreibt in seiner Schreibstube. Denn ja, es ist so ein bisschen zu verkopft und da steckt zu wenig Gefühl und individuelle sorge und der Leser mit vielleicht auch so dem ein oder anderen Fragestellungen drin. Das kann schon sein. Aber es kann auch sein, dass sich der Autor hier selbst einfach in Sicherheit gebracht hat. Das kenne ich ja von mir auch. Als ich damals Redaktionsschluss schrieb, habe ich ja auch so die Handys und so weiter. Aber im Grunde waren es ja teilweise auch Selbstverteidigungssachen gegen die Smartphone regierte Welt wohlwissen, dass ich diese Selbstverteidigung selber noch nicht gut auf die Straße kriege, aber eigentlich auch bräuchte. Also man schreibt dann manchmal auch so ein bisschen. Vielleicht war er auch in so einer Lebensphase, wo ihn dieses ganze Datingzeug besonders kümmerte und er dann plötzlich gemerkt hat, wie er da ausgeliefert ist. Und dann hat er sich in so eine in so eine verkopfte Recherche reingestürzt und ist dann eben auch dabei geblieben, statt das Gefühl, das ihn dazu brachte, wieder zurückzubringen und im Text abzubilden. Kann alles sein.
Er beschreibt ja zum Teil sehr eigenartige Dinge, also dass man dort in Second Life Spielen sich Avatare aufbauen kann, die dann für einen Sex haben. Es werden verschiedene Sexroboter beschrieben. Ich denke, dass diese Trends auch noch weiter zunehmen werden. Das war für mich eine Zeit lang immer so, dass ich dachte, das ist so spezialistisch, das mag es irgendwo auch auf dieser bunten Welt geben, aber das ist vielleicht kein großer Trend. Aber es hat sich zum Beispiel dann bei mir doch dieser Blick darauf nochmal geändert, als ich so eine Statistik mal sah, von dem, was auf den großen Porno-Seiten, also YouPorn und wie das alles ist, heißt, aufgerufen wird. Und das war und das wird hier auch erwähnt, Hentai. Und das habe ich dann gegoogelt. Das sind so Sex-Animes, im Prinzip, wenn ich das jetzt richtig wiedergebe. Ich weiß ja, ob es wirklich Anime ist, aber es sind auf jeden Fall umsetzt ganz banal aus, so Comic-Figuren, die Sex haben, also gezeichnete Figuren, keine Menschen, die Sex haben. Und das war ganz oben immer. Und hier wird ja auch darüber geschrieben, dass man dann weiß, wie dieser Algorithmus da funktioniert und weiß, wenn die Kombination Hentai und Lesbien zusammenkommen, dann gibt das noch mal mehr Klicks. Und so wird dann der Sex strukturiert auf den Plattformen. Was mich jetzt, was ich erst mal auch hier fragen würde, ist nun sind ja diese Plattformen. Und ich will jetzt gar nicht darüber reden, was da alles für einen Schindluder getrieben wird, dass da irgendwelche Videos hochgeladen werden von Leuten, die es nicht wollen, oder dass es natürlich da auch irgendwelche toxischen Beziehungen gibt, die dazu führen, dass dann Frauen sich da prostituieren sollen, zum Beispiel, also davon liest man ja auch immer häufiger. Aber wenn wir das mal gerade beiseite schieben und uns mal nur ansehen, was wird da gezeigt, also wie es würde man jetzt ins Kino gehen, dann stellt man ja erst mal bei diesen Plattformen, die ja wie YouTube funktioniert oder wie ein Streaming-Dienst funktioniert fest, dass es eine enorme Vielfalt gibt, verglichen mit dem, was jetzt eine konventionelle Pornografie produziert, Pornindustrie produziert hat in den 80er, 90er Jahren, wo das ziemlich limitiert war, weil man darauf angewiesen war, ein möglichst großes Publikum zu bekommen und man auch nicht diese weltweite Verstreuung hatte, sondern das war halt in der Videothek und vielleicht kann da mal was aus Amerika hier rüber, aber das war ja jetzt nicht so, dass das international war in diesem Sinne. Und was sich ja doch da herausstellt ist, dass erst einmal diese Plattformen eine viel größere Variation anbieten, als die klassische Pornografie, die jetzt in Deutschland vielleicht mit dem Namen wie Dolly Basta oder so verbunden wäre. Und das führt dabei ja nicht dazu dann wirklich, dass es hier progressiv wird. Also das ist ja auch ein Punkt von ihm, dass er sagt, ja, eigentlich bleibt der Körper wahre oder wird es noch viel mehr. Patriarchale Strukturen bleiben, bestehen. Ganz viele Strukturen, die wir eigentlich überwinden wollten, kommen sogar wieder. Und die Frage, die sich ja dann stellt, liegt das jetzt nur an der algorithmischen Programmierung? Und wie sollte die dann aussehen? Und ich finde, das erfordert die zwar ein, aber wie sollte die aussehen, dass genau dies vermieden wird? Und ich bin da, ja, stehe da vor einem Rätsel.
Ja, ich auch. Und da verstehe ich auch die Herangehensweise. Sagen wir es mal so, auf der Bühne sieht man ja manchmal so Leute wie Sloterdijk oder Louis CK., Männer in höherem Alter, die sehr explizite Scherze über das eigene Dasein machen. Das männliche Dasein jenseits der 40, wo die biologische Funktion erfüllt ist, und man nicht genau weiß, warum ist man eigentlich noch da. Man weiß nur, so ein paar Bedürfnisse hat man noch, aber so richtig befriedigt wäre die eigentlich nicht. Und diesen Büchern wird dann noch mal so thematisiert, dass die, und das hier ganz explizit, die Sex-Boards und die Simulationen, also Gaming und so weiter, die Dating Apps, dass die ja, Zitat, unsere Befriedigungen limitieren, unsere Wünsche kontrollieren und unsere Impulse konstruieren. Also Befriedigungen limitieren, Wünsche kontrollieren, Impulse konstruieren. So, also da steckt so dieses generative Moment der Apps schon drin, aber wir werden dann, uns wird dann gesagt, ja, aber die begrenzen uns ja eigentlich. Eigentlich müssten wir uns ja noch viel mehr ausleben. Gleichzeitig hat man aber wissend eine große Masse an Menschen, die sich eben nicht ausleben kann einfach. Ja, wie viele Menschen sehen wir die, und das ist ja jetzt hier wirklich mal ein Safe Space. Wir können jetzt mal ganz ernsthaft und ehrlich darüber reden. Wie viele Männer sehen wir denn, die einfach 30 Kilo Übergewicht mit sich rumschleppen, von denen wir genau wissen.
Jetzt kommst du wieder mit deinem Übergewicht.
Naja, aber Übergewicht ist nun mal diese zentrale Komponente, weil die so sichtbar ist und so viel Sympathie organisiert. Empathie, sag ich mal so. Wo wir eigentlich genau wissen, diesen Menschen, die haben auch Bedürfnisse, aber denen kannst du noch mit solchen Büchern und Apps und was weiß ich um die Ecke kommen, die sind wirklich limitiert. Und denen dann immer vorzusagen, ja, diese Apps limitieren ganz schön. Eigentlich solltest du dich noch sehr viel mehr ausleben, als du dich schon nicht mit einer App auslebst. Da finde ich, wird es immer so ein bisschen kritisch.
Das hat ja erst mal nichts mit Übergewicht zu tun mit Ausleben, sondern da würde ich eher sagen, ich würde eher sagen, dass die, dass die Apps, also da glaube ich, da sind die Geschmäcker sehr verschieden. Ich glaube, dass die Apps eher dafür sorgen, dass Leute, die es uns schwerer haben, jemanden zu finden, vielleicht weil sie nicht irgendeinem Ideal oder einer Norm entsprechen, also zum einen limitieren sie dadurch, dass sie gerade wie Tinder sagen, du musst toll aussehen hier, zeig dich mit freiem Oberkörper, präsentier dich beim Sport und all das. Also das, was wir auch bei Instagram finden können, wird ja dann nur nochmal verstärkt bei Tinder oder Grindr. Das ist definitiv so und das sorgt auch für einen enormen Druck. Ich glaube im Übrigen auch, dass dieser ganze Druck, der durch diese Bilder erzeugt wird, viele Leute in eine Resignation bringt, dass sie dann sagen, gut, da komme ich eh nicht ran und dann lasse ich es ganz sein. Aber zugleich muss man ja feststellen, ermöglichen diese Apps ja auch Menschen eine Kommunikation mit anderen, mit Gleichgesinnten, die sonst nicht gegeben ist. Also nehmen wir jetzt mal die Grindr App. Es ist ja die Möglichkeit, damit für jeden schwulen Mann gegeben, mit anderen schwulen Männer in Verbindung zu treten. Das hat er ja im Analogen nicht. Also er kann er ja nicht in die Dorfkneipe gehen. Da ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit relativ gering, dass er da jemanden trifft. Und wenn, wie gibt man sich zu erkennen und was weiß ich. Also musste man in entsprechende Bars gehen. Ähnliche Apps gibt es ja auch für lesbische Frauen zum Beispiel. Und dann nochmal spezieller für trans Personen und, und, und. Und da glaube ich, gibt es schon eine große Möglichkeit. Oder ich glaube auch, dass Leute mit, mit Körpern, die nicht der Norm, und das auch nur in Anführungszeichen natürlich, die nicht der Norm sprechen, dass die sich darüber suchen können. Ich weiß aber, was du da eigentlich ansprichst. Und das scheint mir etwas zu sein, was ja ausblendet, obwohl er Zizek rezipiert. Zizek sagt immer, früher war der Psychoanalytiker dafür da, die Leute hinzuführen zur Auslebung ihrer Lüste. Ja, da kommt jemand zu Freud und sagt, ja, ich hab da so komische Träume und so weiter. Und dann, und dann sagt Freud, ich mach's jetzt mal ganz platt, ja wissen Sie, sie sind eigentlich homosexuell. Ist auch gar nicht schlimm. Sie müssen nur sich jetzt einen Partner suchen. Und sie können nicht weiter dem bürgerlichen Weltbild entsprechen. Finden sich damit ab und haben ein schönes Leben. Um das jetzt ganz banal zu sagen. Heute sagt Zizek, ist das große Problem für Psychoanalytiker. Es kommen Leute, weil sie überfordert sind, von dem Dauerappell genießen zu müssen. Die sagen, ja, gut, ich hatte jetzt nur vier Partner in meinem Leben. Und wir haben auch eigentlich so normalen Sex, meistens im Bett. Bin ich noch normal? Muss ich nicht auch Dreifetische entwickeln? Und was ist eigentlich mit diesen Toys? Wie viel brauche ich davon, um normal zu sein, um dem Leistungsanspruch an den Errors zu entsprechen? Und Shijek, so seine These ist, und Eva Elos ist da auf einer ähnlichen Linie, sagt, na ja, heute sind die Psychoanalytiker eigentlich immer mehr damit beschäftigt, den Patienten zu sagen, es ist gar nicht schlimm. Du kannst auch einfach nur einen Partner haben. Du kannst auch ruhig Missionarstellung haben. Du bist nicht pervers, wenn du nur Missionarstellung machen willst.
Genau. Und da sind wir nämlich bei dem Punkt, der ja in dem Buch, ich habe es vorhin schon angesprochen, so wichtig ist, die Sehnsüchte hinter dem Ausleben. Also diese Programmierung der Sehnsüchte selbst. Was sind das für welche? Wo kommen sie her? Und ich finde, wir lesen das ja alles nicht im Luftlernraum. Und ich warte im Grunde auf die große Publikation von Scott Galloway dazu, der sich ja viel solche Gedanken macht. Als Ökonom dann immer da, also so Pseudokonome, wie auch immer. Sagen wir mal Halligalli-Podcaster, der aber immer wieder auf einem festen Fundament steht. Dann so verschiedene Punkte zu machen, wie zum Beispiel, wenn sie als Frau Homeoffice machen, werden sie übersehen, wenn es um die nächsten Beförderungen geht. Weil sie haben dann keine Präsenz und so weiter. Es ist wichtig, dass sie da sind, dass sie da eine gute Figur machen. Das gehört halt leider dazu, auch wenn wir immer überall behaupten, es sei irgendwie anders und wir wären da schon einen Schritt weiter. Und er guckt sich eben seit einer Weile so diese Datingmärkte an und stellt eben fest, Tinder und so weiter, da werden nur 20 Prozent der Männer auf ihre Kosten kommen und 80 Prozent eben nicht. Die Sehnsüchte, und da ist das Buch so wichtig, dass darauf hinwille, die Sehnsüchte werden trotzdem allen reinprogrammiert. Und sei es nur, um betriebswirtschaftlich irgendwie 30 Euro pro Monat aus der Tasche zu ziehen, oder was auch immer. Also diese Art der Programmierung ist da, und trotzdem wird nur die Sehnsucht reinprogrammiert, aber nicht der Sex selbst. Und ich finde bei diesen Apps, klar, die versprechen dann immer etwas, aber in so einem Buch, finde ich, hätte man nochmal das deutlicher machen können, dass diese Programmierung und so weiter, die hier stattfinde, dieses Ganze, das ist ja wirklich eine, wie soll man sagen, also Programmieren ist fast noch zu schwach. Das ist dieses Kontrollieren und so weiter. Man muss alle Begriffe irgendwie reinbringen. Die finden hier statt. Ja, also dieses Lieblingsbeispiel immer wieder, wo gehen wir lange in der fremden Stadt? Näher da, wo Google sagt, via Maps, dass halt der Weg ist. Ja, dass es dann noch bessere Wege gibt oder irgendwie, das ist halt alles ausgeblendet in dem Moment, weil wir haben ja nur das. So.
Und sollten wir nicht da auch nochmal ganz klar nicht jetzt mit dem Analogen an sich kommen, sondern eher mit der Willensfreiheit und sagen, zum Beispiel, alles basiert ganz stark im Silicon Valley, auch wenn man sich diese Leute da anhört, diese CEOs, auf einem sehr deterministischen Weltbild. Und ich habe manchmal den Verdacht, er hat auch ein deterministisches Weltbild, er will es nur anders determinieren. Das würde ich jetzt nicht so weit gehen, dass er wirklich deterministisch ist, aber es gibt auch die Möglichkeit, eine andere Abbiegung zu nehmen. Und das geht aber nur, wenn man tatsächlich es schafft, sich nicht ganz davon vereinnahmen zu lassen, was einem da angeboten wird. Aber um das vielleicht plastisch zu machen, weil wir so ein bisschen im luftleeren Raum natürlich hier sprechen, er bringt ja ein Beispiel aus der Literatur, um zu verdeutlichen, was eigentlich gemeint ist, mit dieser Programmierung, dass es nicht einfach nur darum geht, naja, da wird uns jetzt ein Bild oder so anzeigen, sondern das ganze Arrangement ist wichtig, wie wir zum Beispiel dann Beziehungen wahrnehmen oder wie Sex organisiert ist und so etwas. Er sagt, das ist eigentlich wirklich das Programm, also das ganze Setting, wie ist diese Welt, die da erschaffen wird, gebaut. Und das kann bei der App sein wie bei der Second Life Geschichte. Und er bezieht sich dann auf Goethe. Er kommt ja auch auf Luhmann zu sprechen. Luhmann hat ja den Liebesdiskurs der Romantik analysiert. Er hat sich die Liebesbriefe angesehen, hat sich die Literatur angesehen. Und die These von Luhmann ist, also die Liebe, wie wir sie heute kennen, die hat die Literatur quasi produziert. Der hat die hervorgebracht. Also es gibt ja nicht etwas einfach so Natürliches, dass man sagt, so ist das halt einfach, so wird geheiratet oder so macht man sich Anträge. Sondern das haben wir woher. Und das hat Luman dann nachgezeigt anhand der Literatur. Und jetzt gibt es natürlich andere, einflussreichere Dinge, die so etwas hervorbringen, zum Beispiel Dating Apps. Und jetzt geht ja Alfie Bown auf Goethe zu und sagt, ich zitiere jetzt einfach mal so eine Stelle aus dem Werter. Und ich habe die dann nachgeschlagen, mit der hier die deutsche Fassung haben und lese die mal vor, um zu zeigen, was eigentlich damit gemeint ist. Wenn man sagt, so dieses ganze Arrangement darum, das ist eigentlich das Entscheiden, das strukturiert unser Begehren. Denn Begehren ist ja nicht einfach so, muss so und so groß sein und blonde Haare haben oder so. Also Goethe schreibt im Werter. Ich ging durch den Hof nach dem wohlgebauten Hause und da ich die vorliegenden Treppen hinauf gestiegen war und in die Tür trat, fiel mir das reizendste Schauspiel in die Augen, das ich je gesehen habe. In dem Vorsale wimmelten sechs Kinder von elf zu zwei Jahren um ein Mädchen von schöner Gestalt, mittlerer Größe, die ein simples weißes Kleid mit blassroten Schleifen am Arm und Brust anhatte. Sie hielt ein schwarzes Brot und schnitt ihren kleinen Rings herum, jedem sein Stück nach Proportionen ihres Alters und Appetits ab. Gab's jedem mit solcher Freundlichkeit und jedes rief so ungekünstelt sein Danke, indem es mit den kleinen Händchen lange in die Höhe gereicht hatte, ehe es noch abgeschnitten war und nun mit seinem Abendbrote vergnügt entweder wegsprang oder nach seinem stillen Charakter gelassen davon ging nach dem Hoftor zu, um die Fremden und die Kutsche zu sehen, darin ihre Lotte wegfahren sollte. Was hier geschildert ist, da haben wir das Mädchen, von dem wir nur hören, schöner Gestalt, mittlere Größe, mehr nicht. Und dann kommen wir direkt zu dem, was außerhalb der Person ist, also simples weißes Kleid, blassrote Schleifen am Arm und Brust und so was. Und dann haben wir aber noch diesen ganzen Rahmen darum, also mit den Kindern, die Treppe hinauf, der Vorsaal und all das ist es, was dann das Begehren in Wärter auslöst. Es ist also nicht einfach die Person, dass man sagt, so jetzt habe ich hier die Person, das ist das Begehrenswetter, sondern es ist das ganze Arrangement. Und jetzt übertragen auf eine Dating App bedeutet das natürlich auch, in welchem Arrangement präsentiert man sich, also welche Daten gibt man von sich an? Wie sieht das Bild aus, das man präsentiert? Was ist noch mit auf dem Bild drauf? Ein Cocktail in der Hand oder irgendeine repräsentative Tür im Hintergrund, was auch immer. Und das ist es eigentlich, was uns dazu bringt, etwas zu begehren und nochmal übertragen auf die Apps und auf die ganzen Plattformen bedeutet das natürlich, dass die solche Settings auch für uns herstellen, dass wir sagen, ach, da findet unser Begehren statt, beziehungsweise da artikuliert es sich und so wird die Welt des Begehrens neu geformt.
Genau und er schreibt ja völlig zurecht, bei Luhmann ist dieses Argument, es macht die Kultur noch wichtiger als es macht die Familie. Also selbst das konkrete Umfeld, in dem man Liebe erfährt und wo man aus Liebe entstanden ist, schlägt da so rein wie dieser Literaturbetrieb damals und dann gilt halt, was Schirmerer sagte, also neue Ideen kommen entweder über Bücher oder Technik in die Welt und jetzt ist es eben die Technik. Ich will auch mal was vorlesen, was aktueller ist als Goethe, aber sehr viele junge Menschen eben auch so ein bisschen in diese Verirrung führt und was jetzt die Technik eben ersetzen will. Also das Lied heißt Egal und ist von Lina Larissa Stahl. Ich brauch kein Geld, kein Flug, einmal um die Welt, keine Filter, keinen Like, keinen Hashtag geteilt, keine Autos, kein Bling Bling, kein Gentleman Style, weil du ganz alleine mir reichst. Und muss ich mich entscheiden zwischen dir und der Welt, kennst du meine Wahl, dann ist mir einfach alles andere egal. Und dann egal, egal, egal, egal, egal, so dass auch mein Fünfjähriger sagt, dies Lied will dich in meiner Playlist.
Ja.
So und dieses Aufwiegen der ganzen Welt mit einer Person, was die Bedeutung für das eigene Leben angeht.
Das ist Romantik.
Das ist dieses Ziel, was die Apps jetzt verfolgen.
Das ist Sturmhöhe. Das ist Tristan und die Sollte. Tristan und die Sollte versichern sich im zweiten Akt in der Liebesnacht. Und wenn die ganze Welt verschwindet, du bist mir die Welt. Ganz ähnlich kann man das in Sturmhöhe nachlesen.
So wir wissen aber nicht, ist das für die Ewigkeit und ist das jetzt dystopisch oder utopisch? Und das kann man immer nicht so genau sagen, weil es eben immer alles zusammengehört. Aber es ist der Anspruch dieser Apps, genau das zu sein, wichtiger als die ganze Welt. Es ist mir wichtiger jetzt in der Dating App nachzuschauen, wer mir da geschrieben hat, als alles andere in der Welt.
Und das ist das Entspolitisierende. Es gibt eine sehr schöne Inszenierung von Tristan und die Sollte von Peter Konvitschny. Und Peter Konvitschny, als Regisseur aus der DDR stammt, als Sozialist, hat gesagt, eigentlich ist mir das zu asozial diese Liebe. Die ziehen sich ja zu sich selbst zurück, die sind sich ja selbst genug. Die singen sich ja nur gegenseitig an und wenn der eine stirbt, stirbt die andere gleich nach. Und was macht er? Er lässt die Oper anders enden, also sie singen natürlich, was nicht gehört. Aber dann gehen Tristan und die Solde Hand in Hand hinaus in den Saal. Also sie gehen in die Gesellschaft. Und das ist ja etwas, was auch Alfie Bown eigentlich einfordert, dass die Liebe politisiert wird. Und er schaut sich ja auch, das finde ich auch interessant, müsste man jetzt auch nochmal sich richtig selbst zu Gemüte führen, diese ganzen verschiedenen Dating-Shows im Fernsehen an. Und diese Sachen irgendwie, wir sind nackt auf einer Insel und sind da 14 Tage oder so. Und was ihm da auffällt, ist, komisch, nur Politik die ganze Zeit, Brexit, Boris Johnson oder Trump und und. Und dort, in diesen Shows, keine Spur davon. Und genauso auch bei den Dating Apps. Absolute Entpolitisierung. Und das Lied ist perfekt, um das zu beschreiben. Da auch. Die Welt ist uns egal. Wir sind wir zwei. Das reicht.
Genau. Und dann schneit er eben hier rein, mit so Sätzen wie es ist egal, wie spontan und magisch sich die Liebe anfühlt. Letztlich saß irgendwo jemand und hat sie programmiert. Bei den Dating Apps klar. Aber auch eben es gibt eine sehr lustige Podcast Aufnahme von Conan O'Brien mit einer, die auch so diese Dating Reality-TV-Shows gemacht hat. Die sind auch meinte. Was glaubt ihr denn? Also wir machen uns keine Gedanken darüber, ob die bei uns in Love gehen, weil wir schließen die zusammen für drei, vier Tage. Die können gar nicht anders. Also wir bekommen dann genau, was wir da bestellen als Programmmacher. Wir bekommen eine Liebe vor die Kamera, wo die auch dann wirklich das Fühlen und All in gehen. Und man sitzt als Zuschauer da, denkt, naja gut, okay, die sind eben halt ausgeliefert und so weiter. Aber in dieser Driftigkeit wird hier die Technik beschrieben. Und das finde ich erst mal sehr gut. Man kann sich dann viele eigene Gedanken auch nochmal dazu machen und so weiter. Man kann sich ja dem auch hingeben. Es ist ja nicht so, dass man am Ende über die Dating Apps nicht tatsächlich echte Menschen trifft. Und dann ist das vielleicht auch nur noch so Gründungsgeschichte oder so für was weiß ich, für Beziehungen. Aber es ist eben erst mal wie es ist. Und ja, dieser politische Aspekt, nämlich dass ja alles auch immer anders sein kann. Dass man sich ja durchaus fragen kann, ja, ist es immer das Profitinteresse des Einzelnen? In China sieht man deutlich, wie die Politik da rein regiert, indem sie sagt, na ja, Hauptsache wir haben eine Milieutrennung, dass hier keine großen Volksaufstände entstehen und sich niemanden kennenlernt über die Grenzen hinweg, sondern dass da einfach im Milieu geblieben wird und so weiter und so fort. Und in der Ansicht ist das Buch da schon ziemlich gut. Er hat hier ein Punkt Politik und Liebe. Alain Badiou, wie auch immer.
Ja, Alain Badiou.
2009.
Er hat ein sehr gutes Buch über die Liebe geschrieben, das heißt, der Lob der Liebe.
Genau, In Praise of Love von 2009. So, Politik und Liebe trennen sich schon von der Sphäre, von der Anlage her wie, na ja, im einen gibt es das Konzept des Feindes, das ist die Politik oder des Rivalen. Die Liebe und dann sagt Alfie, ja, schon zehn Jahre später, jetzt sind wir uns nicht mehr so sicher, ob wir das noch so trennen können, denn plötzlich haben wir auch in der Politik, das was wir vorher in der Liebe hatten, dieses ganze Leidenschaftliche, wie schon im Teaser vorhin gesagt, das fand ich eigentlich am faszinierendsten, dass man dieses Bild hat, Familien eigentlich auf Liebe gegründet, zerstreiten sich anhand von politischen Themen. Wo früher noch die kluge Frau des Hauses sagte, am Tisch keine Politik, weil sie genau wusste, wohin sie führt. Jetzt hat man am Tisch Politik. Liebe wird aufgelöst wegen politischer Streiterei. Da gibt es ja tausende Geschichten, die irgendwie journalistisch aufgearbeitet wurden. Und wissend, wie es in der Politik gerade zugeht, das Argument zu nehmen und auch für die Liebe gelten zu lassen. Das finde ich einfach stark. Ohne weitere Argumente erst mal, ohne Formulierung. Einfach nur mal sagen, ja, diese Domäne Liebe hat die ähnlichen Effekte. Also so wie wir bisher die Liebe nicht in der Politik sahen, oder die Leidenschaftlichkeit, und sie ist jetzt drin, steckt die Politik auch in der Liebe. Und ich finde, das ist irgendwie so ein guter Ansatzpunkt, um so grundsätzlich mal über Liebe und Familie nachzudenken. Denn wir haben in Deutschland ja auch ganz viele Probleme, weil wir, Niklas Mark usw., weisen uns ja immer wieder darauf hin, wie bauen wir eigentlich? Wir lieben so, wie wir halt bauen. Man will in ein Familienhaus. Das ist irgendwie das Ziel von allem. Aber dabei bräuchte es doch noch so fünf, sechs andere gute Ideen, aber die gibt es so gar nicht in Deutschland. Leben im Alter, wenn es dann nicht mehr die konkrete individuelle Liebe ist, sondern man will eine große Gemeinschaft und einen kleinen Rückzugsraum usw. Also da sind aus ganz vielen externen Richtungen, passt das irgendwie nicht zu Bedürfnissen, die so da sind. Und da an solchen Punkten sieht man immer, wie scharf rein regiert wird. Und solche Argumentation zu nehmen und sagen, das gilt hier bei dieser technikgetriebenen Liebes-Kreierung auch. Das fand ich wirklich stark.
Badiu als linker Philosoph aus Frankreich bezieht sich hier auf Lacan. Und Lacan sagt, das wird mehrmals zitiert von Alfie Bown, Politik ist Politik, aber Liebe bleibt Liebe. Er versucht also, diese beiden Sphären zu trennen. Und Alfie Bown sagt jetzt, ja, das stimmt aber nur bedingt, denn es ist durchaus politisch, wie zum Beispiel die Dating Apps organisiert sind und wer sich da mit wem connectet. Ist das so, dass man zum Beispiel solche Sektoren schafft für Leute, die besonders reich sind? Oder wie ist es eigentlich mit Verbindungen, die über die eigene Ethnie hinausgehen, wird das eher produziert, dass das stattfinden kann? Also wird das ein offener Raum oder wird das eher einer, wo alles schön voneinander getrennt ist? Das ist eine Frage, die sich für mir stellt. Natürlich, also was diese gesellschaftliche Organisation der Liebe anbelangt, aber ich glaube, dass ich Badu dennoch recht geben würde und auch Lacan, dass auch die Liebe, Liebe bleibt, also dass es da, wo sie dann tatsächlich Realität ist, diese Art der Politisierung in gewisser Weise nicht mehr greift. Hier bin ich auch Romantiker, dass ich schon sagen würde, dass es das geben kann, was alle Koordinaten verändert oder auch die Welt fast verschwinden lässt. Also dass das schon auch da ist. Und da sind wir aber an einem Knackpunkt, den wir jetzt hier nicht vertiefen können, nämlich die Auseinandersetzung mit den Poststrukturalisten und auch der Gendertheorie, inwieweit das alles historisch ist, wie alles organisiert ist und auch die Liebe. Oder ob es doch so etwas wie anthropologische Konstanten gibt, wovon eher die Psychoanalyse ausgeht, wenn man jetzt bei Freud und Lacan nachgeht, was aber jetzt nicht meint, dass die so einen komischen Identitätsdenken und Essenzialismus unbedingt anhängen. Aber das ist etwas, was man sich erst einmal fragen muss, inwieweit man da mitgeht. Was diese Organisation der Liebe anbelangt, dass es dann zu einer Desire Revolution, einer progressiven Desire Revolution wird, frage ich mich, wohin führt uns das? Ich will einen Abschnitt vorlesen. Da heißt es, ich habe den vorab übersetzt, dies könnte als Blaupause für die Entwicklung eines Algorithmus für eine Dating Website dienen, die in der Lage ist, die Art von sozialer Organisation zu durchbrechen, die bei bestehenden Websites üblich ist. Es könnte eine Möglichkeit geschaffen werden, Menschen miteinander zu verbinden, die Daten nutzen, um hilfreiche Vorschläge zu machen und gleichzeitig ein vielfältiges Spektrum soll so an Klassen und kulturbedingten Verbindungen unterstützt werden, die über die Filterblasen hinausreichen, die durch das Internet der Cyber Balkanisierung entstehen. Wenn die Vorschläge auf metonymischen Verbindungen zwischen der verwendeten Sprache und nicht auf der Ähnlichkeit zwischen den Nutzern beruhen, würden alle Daten, die der Nutzer in die Website eingibt, berücksichtigt und genutzt werden, aber der Prozess würde Verbindungen mit Personen, die sich von ihm unterscheiden, nicht ausschließen. Dies könnte zu gelegentlich wenig hilfreichen Vorschlägen führen, wenn das Wort links, also left wing, lautet, würde es metonymisch zu rechts right wing vermittelt, auch wenn es unwahrscheinlich ist, dass diese beiden Nutzer, also left wing right wing Leute, übereinstimmen, wodurch die Website eher das Gegenteil von Trump Dating wäre. Trump Dating ist eine Plattform, wo sich nur Leute treffen, die Donald Trump geil finden. Da der Algorithmus jedoch nicht nur ein, sondern hunderte von Wörtern verwenden würde, wäre eine solche Verbindung unwahrscheinlich vielmehr, würden die Nutzer mit denjenigen in Verbindung gebracht werden, die ähnliche Begriffe, wie sie selbst verwenden. Solche Karten könnten die Grundlage für einen Datensatz bilden, der nicht versucht, den Nutzer mit anderen zu verbinden, die dieselben Wörter verwenden, sondern mit verwandten Wörtern in einer riesigen Big Data-Karte, einer Art Wort-Assoziationsspiel mit Millionen von Spielern und zu einem Modell für die Herstellung von Verbindungen zwischen Menschen aggregiert. In einem solchen Modell würden sie nicht mit Gleichgesinnten in Verbindung gebracht, sondern mit denen, deren Diskurs sich mit dem Ihren verbindet und überschneidet.
Ja, und was ist, wenn es am Ende doch Grundkonstanzen gibt? Wir haben überhaupt erst mal eine romantische Liebe über die Literatur, so wie Luma das aufgearbeitet hat. Alle lesen also, wie man mit Frauen umgeht und was Männer so beitragen müssen. Und dann macht man das. Denn Eva Illouz, die er hier nennt, oder auch Shulmaid Firestone, den ich nicht kenne, die ja noch mal mit diesem, ja, am Ende, es sind die reichen Männer, die bestimmen über die Gefühlslagen. Ob das jetzt über Apps oder vorher anders und wie auch immer, ob jemand in die Kneipe reinkommt und da einfach nach Geld aussieht und entsprechend attraktiv ist oder halt über drei Fotos in so einer App. Und die Ungleichheit ist eben die Grundlage für Gefühlsentwicklungen. Gerade Frauen, die viel nach Sicherheit sich sehnen, ignorieren dann vieles und wollen dann einfach jemanden, der das bietet. Männer, weiß man auch, wonach sie sich so sehnen. Und dann gehen sie halt auf die etwas jüngeren Frauen, weil dann die Attraktivität noch so eine große Rolle spielt. So und da so ein wohlwollend, ein Technikblick draufzulegen, um zu sagen, ja, die Technik kann vieles und sie sollte jetzt auch das mal aufbrechen und zur neuen Freiheit führen. Wie schon vorhin gesagt, das ist dann immer, keine Ahnung, da kann man mir noch so viel mit irgendwelchen Name Dropping und hier noch eine Idee und da und so. Das ist dann, ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das nicht doch alle so in die große Verwirrung und eben nur zur Sehnsucht, aber nicht zum Sex, den sich dann alle wünschen, führt. Also da ist das Buch, hängt dann auch so ein bisschen in der Luft.
Und hier würde ich sagen, auch wieder die Lösung liegt außerhalb. Die Lösung dafür, dass es solche hierarchischen Beziehungen gibt, wo die Ökonomie eigentlich die Liebe regiert, liegt ja darin, dass wir nicht eine Gleichheit haben. Wenn wir zum Beispiel ökonomische Gleichheit zwischen Mann und Frau in unserer Gesellschaft hätten und auch eine entsprechende Absicherung, wenn man Alleinerziehendes und so weiter, würden sich ja gewisse Abhängigkeitsmuster gar nicht herausbilden. Das kann mir aber nicht die App lösen. Also das ist so, Soluzionismus würde Morozov sagen, dass man sagt, gut, jetzt bräuchten wir mal eine App, die das anders miteinander connectet. Nee, das ökonomische Problem bleibt ja für die Frau bestehen. Und da könnte man ja etwas dran tun, dass es gewisse Begehungsstrukturen gibt, die vielleicht schwer zu verändern sind. Also da weiß ich auch nie, was ist das progressive Begehren jetzt? Also ich weiß, ich kann sagen, was repressiv wäre. Also wenn jemand das, was er sich wünscht und was legal ist, nicht ausleben kann, dann ist das eine Repression, die er erfährt aus irgendwelchen Gründen von der Familie, unterdrückt, was auch immer. Aber wurde eingeimpft bekommen, ist ja auch wieder. Aber genau, aber sonst weiß ich nicht, ob mein Begehren, weil ich jetzt Marx gelesen habe, irgendwie in dem Sinne progressiv sind. Also wirklich, wenn wir jetzt über den Akt sprechen. Also da wüsste ich nicht, was ich da nennen soll, beziehungsweise man ist da in so einem Nebel plötzlich. Und das klingt dann so, also man verliebt sich ja dann irgendwann auch in diese progressive Attitüde hinein. Diesen Eindruck habe ich hier mitunter bei manchen Passagen, wo man einfach sagen kann, ja braucht es jetzt auch gar nicht. Und hier, wie das dann programmiert sein soll über Worte, Assoziationsspiele und so etwas, das ist mir wenig stichhaltig. Und genauso wenig stichhaltig ist mir, wenn auf diese Extreme gegangen wird, also was es da alles an vielleicht Virtual Reality Erfahrungen gibt. Hier finde ich, sagt das Internet uns doch auch wieder zugleich das Gegenteil. Also mag sein, dass da irgendwelche Sachen entwickelt werden, wo man eine Brille aufzieht und auch irgendwelche Sensoren an den Körper bekommt. Und dann fühlt sich das fast so an, als hätte man irgendwie eine sexuelle Begegnung. Aber was hat eigentlich den großen Aufstieg während der Corona-Pandemie, die ja geprägt war durch Einsamkeit, durch Nicht-Sex-Haben für Singles, was hat da den Aufstieg erlebt? OnlyFans. Was ist OnlyFans? OnlyFans ist tatsächlich der Ersatz für die, in Anführungszeichen, normale sexuelle Beziehung, dass man jemanden hat, den man wieder sieht. Deswegen abonniert man ihn. Man zahlt da Geld und man abonniert ihn. Und man bekommt Amateuraufnahmen zugesicht. Das heißt, dass Leute filmen, fotografieren sich selbst. Also das, was man in einer Beziehung auch machen könnte, oder man begegnet sich, dann braucht man sich nicht fotografieren. Das fehlt im Alltag ganz vielen Menschen. Und sie sagen, das bekomme ich nicht, wenn ich auf eine normale Promenoplatform gehe, wo irgendwelche Profis einfach nur 30 Minuten eine Performance aufführen, sondern ich will diese direkte Ansprache. Und ich will auch, dass mir noch jemand schreibt, hey, ich freu mich, wenn dir das Foto gefällt, und sag doch mal, was du dir am nächsten Tag von mir wünschst. Und diese Art der parasozialen Beziehung, weil sie als soziale Beziehung sich nicht realisieren ließ, wegen Pandemie und auch anderen Dingen, die ist das, was gewünscht ist. Deswegen, glaube ich, muss man da gar nicht so pessimistisch sein, dass wir da bald alle mit VR-Brillen rumrennen.
Genau. Und das wird aber im Buch leider so gar nicht thematisiert. Stattdessen verliert es sich so in diesem, ja, das Spiel kann ja auch zur Realität führen. Und wenn man in der Spielrealität kritisiert, vielleicht kann man auch neue begründen. Das sind alles solche Sachen. Dieses Pornokapitel, was ja drinsteckt und dann eben diesen Schlenker zum Headset macht und so weiter. Oder wie du eben auch schon dieses Anime. Das Anime Zeug ist vielleicht für die Leute, die eigentlich für sich befriedigte sechs Leben haben, aber dann sowas nochmal wollen. Weil ansonsten würde ich auch sagen, dass was wir bei Corona gelernt haben, ist ja Only Fans. Und die Leute würden sogar weiterhin Only Fans, nur weil sie wissen, das ist wenigstens eine echte Person. Und ich habe mich selbst dafür entschieden, sie ihr zu abonnieren, also ihr zu folgen.
Ich sehe sie in ihrer häuslichen Sphäre, also da, wo ich auch gerne wäre, mit jemand anders zusammen.
Genau, dass das vielleicht den Leuten für immer wichtiger bleibt, als, und da gibt es ja sogar noch einen kleinen, wenn auch nur einen Satz lang, Schlenker zu Westworld, wo man seine tiefsten Sehnsüchte ausleben kann, aber immer nur wohl wissend, sind keine echten Menschen. Die sehen einfach nur aus wie echte Menschen, aber sind keine echten. Sobald hier die Szene rum ist und ich mich ausgelebt habe, kommen die in die Werkstatt, werden repariert und am nächsten Tag kann ich das gleiche nochmal machen und keiner weiß von nichts und so weiter. Ich finde, solche Bücher sollten auch immer was zu den Hormonen selbst sagen. Also Oxytocin, Dopamin, Serotonin und so, weil die unterscheiden sich da einfach ganz groß. Es wird kein Oxytocin am Bildschirm ausgelöst, es sei denn, man kennt diese Personen, um die man da sieht, wirklich. Und es ist wirklich die eine exklusive Person, mit der man sich sexuell auslebt, aber dann halt mal via Smartphone. So, dass da so ein bisschen Vorfreude oder Erfahrung, Erinnerungen drinsteckt und eben nicht nur die rein Bildschirm vermittelte, weil da ist mit Oxytocin fast nichts zu holen. Und dann ist es aber auch ein ganz anderes Erleben, also da trennen sich wirklich die Welten. Und das müsste man eigentlich auf diesem Körperlevel, also fast chemisch, biologisch, hätte man es noch mal beschreiben müssen, um hier auch einigen technophilen Sachen so ein bisschen den Wind aus den Segeln zu nehmen, die da eben doch immer wieder so reinrutschen in solche Texte. Wenn man sich da so drin verliert, was in China halt so alles gemacht wird, weil da ist auch viel Verzweiflung dabei. Und es sind viele Vermeidungs- und Ersatz- und irgendwie Simulationen und Stimulationen über Simulationen, aber eben doch nur Simulationen und so weiter. Also da müsste man so insgesamt ein bisschen ehrlicher irgendwie damit umgehen.
Und ich denke auch, richtig ist der Ansatz der Politisierung, dieser Plattformen, denn warum sollte man nicht auch diese Plattformen politisieren? Das fordern wir ja auch längst ein bei all den Dingen, die so neu entwickelt werden. Eigentlich müsste jeder Politiker, so eine Apple Keynote, sich immer ansehen und sich fragen, müssen wir da irgendwo eingreifen oder wird uns da sogar etwas offeriert, was wir politisch aufgreifen, was wir jetzt für andere verpflichtend machen? Und genauso glaube ich auch muss eine Auseinandersetzung, eine politische eher mit diesen Dating Apps, mit diesen Plattformen auch hier ist es natürlich sinnvoll, wenn nicht das von drei, vier Konzernen gemacht wird, die natürlich kein Interesse haben, die Welt zu verbessern, sondern das Vermögen zu erhöhen. Und ja, ich glaube auch, dass sehr viele dieser Plattformen teils hochproblematisch organisiert und programmiert sind und dass sich darin widerspiegelt, was in unserer Gesellschaft auch da ist. Und sicherlich kann man auch von der anderen Seite, also über Programmierung die Gesellschaft wiederum ändern. Das ist ja so ein bisschen diese Idee hier, die damit schwingt. Aber ich glaube, das ist sehr limitiert, solange sich nicht andere Ungleichheiten minimiert, solange die nicht minimiert werden. Generell glaube ich aber, ist es schon wichtig, dass man Sexualität politisiert, aber nicht in so einer nebulösen Weise. Und dann treten wir damit in den Diskurs und was weiß ich alles. Da muss man auch sagen, das bleibt dann doch sehr akademisch. Und dann ist kein Wunder, dass man damit auch nicht viele Leute erreichen wird. Und das müsste man ja tun, um wirklich dann diese Matrix, die hier beschrieben wird, zu verändern.
Genau. Ich will zum Ende zwei Punkte aufgreifen, die mir noch sehr gefallen haben, auch aus inspirativen Gründen für später oder Küchengespräche, die man so führt. Das eine ist ganz am Schluss. Es wird noch mal Richard Stallman und Lawrence Lessig genannt, also Free Software, Free Culture. Und das fand ich irgendwie einen guten Schlusspunkt, um nochmal darauf hinzuweisen. Ja, alles was hier besprochen wurde, die Technologie ist natürlich hergestellt. Und da hat sich also jemand vorher einen Plan und ein Programm gemacht und hat es dann einfach durchgezogen. Und am Ende war im App Store eine Software und die nutzen jetzt irgendwie alle. Und da kann man also grundsätzlich überall eingreifen. Das sind keine sozialen Selbstläufer, so wie der Tanz T auch irgendwann anbraunen werden muss und so. Und es gibt eine sehr schöne Schlusspoente im Buch, als er nämlich schreibt, es wäre doch schön, wenn die so wichtigen Software-Hinies im Silicon Valley mal was richtiges und wichtiges machen würden, statt immer nur für die ein Prozent zu arbeiten. Ja, was wäre, wenn die all das, was sie können, wirklich mal für die gesamte Gesellschaft einsetzen würden und nicht nur für das Profitstreben der Einzelnen, die dann über Bande eben denken, ach, das ist eine Marktlücke, also mache ich mal Dating Apps. Also das ist ein ganz wichtiger Punkt.
Vielleicht kann man das direkt in die Tat umsetzen, denn es sind ja gerade sehr viele arbeitslos geworden in einem Sektor, nämlich im Kryptosektor. Du weißt, da sind viele Leute entlassen worden für all diese Apps und Mining-Geschichten und was weiß ich. Und das sind ja sehr fähige Leute, da haben ja nicht irgendwelche Stümper gearbeitet. Und die könnten doch jetzt was Sinnvolles machen.
Genau, bitte orientiert euch um und schreibt. Die Software muss nicht free sein, aber die Culture, die dadurch entsteht, das wäre schön, wenn die so ein bisschen entfesselt wäre. Und das andere ist so ein Hinweis auf Libido Politik. So, also die Sphäre Politik und liebe Freundschaft sind also nicht ganz so entkoppelt, wie man glaubt, denn du hast ja Trump, Dating und so weiter. Menschen verlieben sich ineinander, nur weil sie den gemeinsamen politischen Feind haben. Man begegnet sich, man trifft sich, man ist bei Veranstaltungen und da findet eine große Schose statt. Und Libido Politik ist Politik, die weniger an den Inhalten ansetzt, als an diesen Methoden. Und um was es genau geht, hört man sofort, wenn ich sage, die Rechten können das besser. Brexit, Trump, sie wirklich bei den Instinkten packen, sie in Gemeinschaften zusammenschmeißen, Meme-Kultur pflegen, genau, der ganze Kram. Und das sollte auch ein Auftrag für linke Politik sein. Hier einfach keine Angst vor was weiß ich, nur weil man glaubt, das ist zu billig oder so. Nee, wenn es Leuten Spaß macht, bitte machen, denn man kann auch ein bisschen mit Schlager und mit Fackeln und mit allem, was man nicht mag.
Bitte keine Fackeln. Also vielleicht können wir uns auf einen, dass wir nicht mit Fackeln mehr arbeiten in der deutschen Politik. Aber sonst können wir gern auch mal den Schlager einsetzen.
Zum Beispiel.
Das ist alles richtig. Ich muss ja noch die Frage beantworten, die ich aufgegriffen habe.
In.
Wie fern wir erhalten das, was wir begehren oder wir gesagt bekommen, was wir begehren sollen, also unser Begehren sich erst durch die Porno Seite, durch die Dating App herausstellt. Und ich glaube, die Antwort von Alfie Bown ist sehr stark. Die Formen, was wir begehren, was wir vorher noch nicht begehrt haben. Ich würde es ein bisschen abschwächen und sagen, nicht im ganz grundsätzlichen Sinne wird da geformt, was wir begehren. Also es wird nicht so sein, dass man sich nur lange genug das eine ansehen muss und dann begehrt man etwas plötzlich völlig anderes oder so. Also um jetzt ein Beispiel zu nehmen, der Homosexuelle wird nicht durch heterosexuelle Pornografie umerzogen werden oder so. Also sonst wären wir im Reich dieser furchtbaren Konversionstherapien. Aber es ist natürlich so, dass und das gilt ja auch genauso für das Kino, damit beschäftigt mich er deshalb auch. Es geht natürlich, dass unser Begehren extrem dadurch geprägt wird, wie wir dem da ausgesetzt sind. Also für mich war das auch zum Beispiel eine interessante Erfahrung, als ich für das Influencer Buch recherchierte und dann mit Ole das Fitness Influencer Kapitel schrieb, das Körper Kapitel und wir dann wirklich so zwei, drei Wochen nur Fitness Influencer uns ansahen. Was passierte eigentlich? Und natürlich formt das einen selbst. Also nicht in der Form, dass ich dann gleich ins Fitnessstudio gerannt bin, aber man glaubt plötzlich, dass der eigene Körper ungeheuer defizitär ist. Aber das ist einfach nur, weil ich die ganze Zeit in einer unglaublichen Nähe und Vielfalt diese perfekt scheinbar perfekt geformten Körper sehe. Und deswegen, glaube ich, ist auch da wieder mein Weg zu sagen, man darf sich dem nicht zu viel aussetzen, damit man nicht zu sehr davon geprägt ist. Denn das erhöht natürlich den Druck. Und wir haben ja auch Essstörungen und alles in der Gesellschaft. Genau deshalb.
Genau. Einmal den Benchmark gesetzt, sitzt so in der Falle. Und da passt ja auch noch zum Schluss das schöne Bild von Clive Scott, das hier aufgegriffen wird. Wir kennen ja alle lieber auf den ersten Blick. Und hier heißt es Love at Last-Side durch dieses endlose Swipen. Man hat gar keinen ersten Blick mehr und verliebt sich sofort, sondern man denkt, ja, der Stapel ist ja noch riesig. Ich guck mal noch weiter. Ich guck mal noch weiter. Und dann ist man nur noch am Weitergucken und vertieft so gar nichts und surft dann nur einmal über das Angebot drüber. Und das fand ich einen guten Kontrast. Liebe auf den ersten Blick als echte Liebe oder beziehungsweise zumindest echte Begegnung oder eben Love at last Swipe, würde man in dem Falle sagen. Und ja, wann ist schon der letzte Swipe? Da kommt natürlich nie. Und das ist ja der Sinn und Zweck dieser Doom Scrolling Apps, die dich natürlich auch nächsten Monat noch zum Swipen begrüßen wollen. Also in Ansicht, ja, interessantes Buch.
Man kann es lesen, man muss es nicht unbedingt lesen, wäre mein Fazit.
Richtig.
Sex Toys, Dating Plattformen oder auch Porno Plattformen geben uns nicht einfach, was wir begehren, sondern sie bilden unser Begehren erst aus. Sie sagen uns, was wir begehren sollen. Das ist auch die These von Alfie Bown in seinem Buch Dreamlovers. Ein bisschen verheddert sich der Autor mitunter in poststrukturalistischen Theorien, aber dennoch zeigt er, dass man die Liebe und den Sex politisieren sollte.
Und am Ende lässt sich alles über Bande lesen. Wer sich schon immer gefragt hat, wie es sein kann, dass sich Familien am Küchentisch wegen Politik zerstreiten, kann im Buch inspirativ nachlesen. Da muss man sich ein paar eigene Gedanken machen, wie es denn sein kann, dass man sich so Hals über Kopf, aber doch irgendwie komisch neuerdings verliebt. Man weiß nicht so genau, sollte man sich wirklich darauf einlassen oder nicht. Und am Ende hat man halt einfach nur eine Wahl getroffen und kann aber auch nach vier Jahren neu wählen.
Wir müssen über Disney sprechen und über Hollywood und über China. Alissa Wilkinson hat ein Interview geführt mit einem Mann, der tatsächlich tief recherchiert hat, was ist da eigentlich los mit Hollywood und China, nämlich mit Erich Schwarzel. Der hat auch ein Buch darüber geschrieben, Red Carpet Hollywood, China und der Kampf um die globale Vorherrschaft. So der deutsche Titel, aber das Buch ist nicht auf Deutsch erschienen. Ich habe es nur jetzt gerade übersetzt, also diesen Artikel, um ein paar Passagen daraus vorzulesen. Und zwar ist es so, dass die großen Hollywood Filme natürlich immer noch im Kino laufen sollen, aber auch auf Streamingdiensten. Und irgendwann hat man gesagt, er ganz wichtig ist für uns eigentlich das chinesische Kino. Und warum ist dieser chinesische Revilis erst jetzt auf dem Radar, kann man sich fragen. Denn das ist schon eine Weile her, dass überhaupt ausländische Filme in China gezeigt werden. Hier steht, bis 1994 waren die meisten Filme in den chinesischen Kinos staatlich geförderte Erzählungen über die chinesische Geschichte und Persönlichkeiten, die in der Regel den Ruhm der kommunistischen Partei verherrlichten. Dann begann die Regierung eine begrenzte Anzahl von Hollywood-Filmen ins Land zu lassen, angefangen mit einem Film mit Harrison Ford. So, inzwischen ist China für Hollywood ein sehr wichtiger Markt. Schorzel hat das deshalb einmal gründlicher recherchiert. Gibt es da irgendwelche Einflussnamen von China auf Hollywood? Sein Buch beschreibt eine faszinierende Reihe von Drehungen und Wendungen, die zeigen, wie die chinesische Regierung von Hollywood gelernt hat und sich nun einer neuen Phase in ihre eigenen Unterhaltungslandschaft zuwendet, mit dem Ziel, Hollywood-Filme als weltweite Unterhaltung abzulösen. Und das würde natürlich bedeuten, dass sich die globale Wahrnehmung sowohl Chinas, als auch der USA zumindest teilweise ändern würde. Also wir beobachten jetzt zum einen Einflussnahme von China auf Hollywood-Produktionen, aber auch, dass China selbst quasi Hollywood macht. Das wundert mich gar nicht. Ich habe darüber mal vor, ich glaube, drei Jahren oder vier Jahren im Freitag geschrieben. Ich habe nämlich chinesische Blockbuster angesehen. Und da habe ich dann festgestellt, die sind ja eigentlich so, wie man es aus Hollywood-Blockbustern kennt. Also die übernehmen stark diese Ästhetik. Es wird auch Thema werden dann in meinem Filmbuch. Es heißt hier jetzt von Schwarze, jeder Film, der in China gezeigt werden soll, muss von der kommunistischen Partei Chinas zur Veröffentlichung freigegeben werden. Wenn also ein Studio einen Film, den es in China zeigen will, abgeschlossen hat, muss es eine Kopie des Films an das Propagandaministerium schicken, wo er einer Gruppe von Leuten vorgeführt wird. Schwarze sagt jetzt, ich habe versucht herauszufinden, wer diese Leute sind. Es hat sich herausgestellt, dass es sich oft um Parteibürokraten handelt, die sich irgendwie durchmogeln. Sie setzen sogar pensionierte Filmwissenschaftler in den Raum, um nach tieferen subtextuellen Bedeutungen von Filmen zu suchen. Wäre ja vielleicht auch noch eine Aufgabe für mich, wenn es alles nicht mehr so gut läuft, mal mit Podcasts, ich dann Subtexte suche für die chinesische Regierung. Sie können sagen, dass der Film ohne Änderung zur Freigabe freigegeben wird, oder er wird zur Veröffentlichung freigegeben, wenn man diese Dinge streicht und dann zählen sie was auf. Also es gibt natürlich das ganz offensichtliche. Kein Studio wird einen Film über den Dalai Lama drehen und den überhaupt versuchen, Hollywood anzudrehen, äh, China anzudrehen. China guckt da sehr genau natürlich drauf. Aber, sagt Schwarze, es gibt noch andere, weniger offensichtliche Bedenken, die die Partei im Laufe der Zeit hatte. Eine davon sind Filme, die Zeitreisen beinhalten. Denn eine Welt, in der es Zeitreisen gibt, bedeutet auch, dass es eine Geschichte gibt, die sich von derjenigen unterscheidet, die die Partei vorgibt.
Hm, dann wie macht Marvel das da in China? Gibt es da kein Marvel, oder?
Sehr guter Punkt, kommen wir jetzt gleich zu. Außerdem wurden homosexuelle Elemente und Geschichten, in denen gleichgeschlechtliche Paare oder homosexuelle Figuren in Filmen vorkommen, sehr genau geprüft und offen gesagt abgelehnt. Also Homophobie in China war ein ganz großes Thema. Filme, die sie unbedingt haben wollen, waren immer die größten. Also Marvel-Filme, Transformers-Filme, Jurassic Park, das sind die Art von Filmen, die die Studios typischerweise für die Veröffentlichung in China vorgesehen haben. Aber es gibt da tatsächlich Probleme mit Marvel, aber auch mit anderen Filmen. Also hier heißt es zum Beispiel, also erst mal mal, bevor wir zu Marvel kommen, noch ein anderes Beispiel. Es gibt diesen Film Good Company mit Dennis Quaid von 2004. Und da sagten dann die Zensoren, nun in der Geschichte geht es um einen jungen Mann, der einen Job bekommt und seinen vorgesetzten ablöst. Das ist ein Thema, das wir hier nicht dulden können, denn es bedeutet, dass man die Älteren nicht respektiert und stattdessen die Autorität herausfordert. Jeder Handlungsstrang, der dieses Thema weiterführt, könnte sich als Riss in der Stabilität erweisen, die wir hier immer aufrecht zu erhalten versuchen. Also es ist interessant, dass das ja etwas ist, wo man überhaupt nicht dran denkt. Also so ein typisches Narrativ, das sagt Schwarzeland auch. Eigentlich der Großteil des Hollywood-Kinos sieht immer so aus. Na ja, und dann kommen halt die Neuen und bekommen den Job oder machen es besser und dann schmeißt man den Chef raus oder was auch immer. Das funktioniert nicht. Er sagt dann auch die Außenseiter, die Hollywood natürlich auch glorifiziert, wenn auch sehr konsumgerecht, wie zum Beispiel in Ferris macht blau, ist in China nicht vorstellbar, lassen die Behörden nicht zu. Disney braucht China, um weiter wachsen zu können. Nun gibt es aber Probleme bei Disney, denn Disney hat sich ja extrem vergrößert. Erstmal, das ist für Disney positiv, also Lucasfilm gekauft, Marvel gekauft und und und. Und ein Hauptpfeiler des großen Star Wars-Plans von Disney war auch, das natürlich in China in die Kinos zu bringen. Und dann sagt Schwarzl, aber erinnern sie sich, als 2015 The Force Awakens herauskam? Der Erfolg des Films beruht zu einem großen Teil auf der Nostalgie für die ursprüngliche Trilogie und dem tiefen Bewusstsein des Publikums für diese. Als Disney den Film in China herausbrachte, war das Publikum mehr als verwirrt. An einer Stelle gibt es eine Szene, in der Han Solo und Chewbacca den Millennium Falcon betreten und Han Solo sagt, Chewie, wir sind zu Hause. In China dachten die Kinobesucher, das bedeute, dass er auf dem Schiff lebt. Diese Klugt wurde im Laufe der Filme immer deutlicher und die Investition in die Figuren und die Handlung, die für das amerikanische Publikum ein Segen war, kam dem chinesischen Publikum wie eine Hausaufgabe vor. Also man muss sich erstmal jetzt da einarbeiten in den Kosmos, um das überhaupt zu verstehen. Dann hat man natürlich auch Disney Channel im chinesischen Fernsehen und hat auch versucht, da Kampagnen für zu machen. Und Disney hat tatsächlich Englischschulen ins Leben gerufen in China, um Kinder so an den Disney-Content besser gewöhnen zu können. Es ist ganz absurd und dann sagt Schwarzl, ich ging an eine dieser Schulen vorbei, als ich dort war und ich erinnere mich, dass in dieser Woche Toy Story 4 herauskam. Alle Lehrer trugen Toy Story 4 T-Shirts. Habe ich auch noch nie vorher gehört, wenn es das so ist. Und nun ist es aber so, dass er sagt, in den letzten fünf Jahren, vor allem bei den großen Action-Blockpassen begannen, ich einen Trend zu bemerken. Und zumindest dachte ich, ich würde einen Trend bemerken. Ein chinesischer Schauspieler, der in einem Filmmitspiel macht irgendeinen Witz auf Mandarin. Normalerweise wurde er nicht übersetzt oder mit Untertiteln versehen, was mir signalisierte, dass es sich nicht um einen Witz handelte. Das ist in Ordnung, es macht Sinn, das zu tun. Aber was ich erkennen konnte, war, dass der Witz auf Kosten einer der weißen Figuren ging, was in einem Hollywood-Film eher ungewöhnlich ist. Der letzte, an den ich mich erinnere, ist der Film Moonfall, der letzten Winter herauskam. Die chinesische Figur kichert darüber, aber es wird nicht übersetzt, worüber sie kichert. Und man versteht den Satz nur, den Witz nur, wenn man die Schriftzeichen lesen kann. Also man versucht tatsächlich da sowas für das chinesische Publikum mit einzubringen, damit die was haben, was wir aber auch besser gar nicht verstehen sollen. Es wird immer unsicherer, was eigentlich wirklich durchkommt, beziehungsweise was eigentlich jetzt stattfindet, ist nicht, dass Hollywood mal was hinschickt und dann vielleicht noch mal was ändert, sondern das große Problem, sagt Schwarzl, ist die Selbstzensur. Dass man also schon von Anfang an mit der Schere im Kopf arbeitet. Es ist leicht zu erkennen, wie schnell man von einer Zensurkultur zur Selbstzensur überging. Als die Filmstudies in 90er Jahren begannen, ihre Filme nach Hollywood zu bringen, sahen sie nicht nur welche ihre eigenen Filme zugelassen und abgelehnt wurden, sondern auch welche anderen Filme zugelassen oder abgelehnt wurden. So hatte man sehr schnell einen Datenpool, aus dem man sagen könnte, dieser Film wurde nicht angenommen oder diese Szene musste gekürzt werden. So können wir bereits auf der Ebene des Drehbuchs damit beginnen, diese Filme so zu verändern, dass wir nicht in diese Probleme geraten. Das heißt, China macht gerade Politik, ohne dass das noch irgendwo transparent wird. Und unsere Filme verändern sich. Und da sind wir eigentlich schon wieder bei Alfie Bown. Also, was wir da für eine Begehrenstruktur präsentiert bekommen, wird jetzt nicht nur von Hollywood und von alten weißen Männern und so weiter hergestellt. Das ist ja der große Diskurs der letzten zehn Jahre, sondern China spielt da eine ganz wichtige Rolle. Das geht dann mal ganz plump, wo darf da irgendwo ein böser Chinese auftauchen und wo ist das nicht gestattet? Eigentlich sollen Chinesen immer positiv gezeichnet werden. Aber es zeigt sich auch, dass man bei Marvel durchaus bereit ist, immer mehr Zugeständnisse zu machen für den chinesischen Markt. Aber das klappt dann nicht. Und da gibt es jetzt was interessantes. Es gibt ja diese amerikanische Forderung, sagt Schwarze, nach mehr, nach besserer Repräsentation in Filmen. Und diese Filme sollen aber vor allem auch den chinesischen Markt erschließen, weil das ja auch ein Wachstumsmarkt ist. Aber es werden da dann einige Steine in den Weg gelegt. Ich gebe Ihnen ein Beispiel, sagt er. The Eternals war der erste Film der Regisseurin Chloe Cao, nachdem sie den Oscar für Nomadland gewonnen hatte. Ihre Einstellung war offensichtlich, zumindest teilweise auf den Ruf zurückzuführen, neue Stimmen in diese Art von Filme zu bringen. Also auch andere Leute zu repräsentieren. Doch während der Oscar-Kampagne wurde sie in China zur Persona non crata, nachdem jahrelang landeskritische Äußerungen von ihr wieder aufgetaucht waren. Es ist schwer zu sagen, ob das genau der Grund war, warum The Eternals nicht in den chinesischen Kinos lief, aber es ist zumindest eine gute Vermutung. Weitere Marvel-Beispiel, Shang-Chi. Hast du den gesehen?
Nein.
Sehr schlechter Film.
Hab ich auch noch gar nicht gehört. Shang-Chi, ist das ein Ort?
Da wollte man auch. Das ist ein Film. Von Marvel. Ja, das ist auch so die Legende von Shang-Chi. Und der sollte auch erfolgreich sein. Und da heißt es jetzt, ironischerweise läuft der Film, aber in China überhaupt nicht, weil sehr wahrscheinlich der Hauptdarsteller nicht mehr genehm ist. Denn der Hauptdarsteller, Simu Liu, der hat sich eben vor Jahren auch kritisch zu China geäußert. Also es ist sehr, sehr verrückt. Vielleicht noch eine abschließende Anekdote. Wir haben ja auch schon darüber gesprochen, China ist sehr interessiert an Afrika. Und da sagt Schwarzl Folgendes. Für dieses Buch bin ich nach Kenia gereist, wo China wirtschaftlich und durch Satellitenunterhaltung auf dem Vormarsch ist. Eine der verblüffendsten Begegnungen hatte ich mit einem jungen, schwulen Mann in Kenia, der in einem Land lebt, in dem sich der Unterhaltungsminister mit China und der chinesischen Zensur arrangiert. Er erzählte mir immer wieder von den Umgehungsmöglichkeiten, die er finden musste, um Filme wie Call Me By Your Name zu sehen oder um auf Filme zuzugreifen, die sie und ich mit ein paar Googlesuchen finden können. Die Vorsichtsmaßnahmen, die er bei der Arbeit treffen muss, für den Fall, dass die Leute herausfinden, dass er schwul ist, was er in Bezug auf das, was seine Familie über sein Leben weiß, zu bewältigen hat. Man sieht, wie die Bilder auf der Leinwand und die Erzählungen, die die Filme hervorbringen, sich schnell auf das Leben außerhalb des Bildschirms übertragen und dieses reflektieren. Das ist also noch mal eine schöne Anknüpfung. Also dieses Interview empfehle ich sehr. Ich verlinke das, wir verlinken das natürlich. Es ist bei vox.com erschienen.
Das ist eine sehr gute Seite. Ähnlich gut wie die New York Times. Dort ist nämlich ein Text zu einem ganz ähnlichen Thema erschienen von Elisabeth Harris und Alexandra Alter. Sie besuchen oder schreiben über Martha Hickson. Das ist eine Highschool Librarian, also eine Bücherei Frau, die sich darum kümmert, dass alles am rechten Flecke steht in den Bücherregalen in New Jersey. Und da hat diese Martha ein so ein Schoolboard Meeting geguckt. Das ist ja gerade in Amerika so eine heiße Sache, dass da Politik wirklich auf unterstem Level gemacht wird, nämlich wenn die Schulen eigentlich sich da organisieren. Und in diesem Livestream der eigenen Schule fiel ihr Name mehrfach, weil irgendwelche Eltern meinten, sie müssen sich jetzt mal darüber beschweren, was in der Bücherei der Schule für Texte verfügbar sind für die Kinder. Und da ist man voll in der identitätspolitischen Diskussion, denn diesen Büchern wird dann unterstellt, die bringen irgendwie die Kinder auf falsche Gedanken, irgendwas mit Homosexualität hier und falschen Vorstellungen da und so weiter. Aber dass eben namentlich dann die Mitarbeiter der Bücherei ausgerufen werden, genannt werden, das ist doch irgendwie neu. Und dadurch, oder so, wurden diese Büchereien da wirklich zum Kriegsgebiet dieser großen politischen Auseinandersetzung. Und der Text handelt dann davon, wie dann auch mal die Proud Boys davor fahren und naja, ihre Vorwürfe entsprechend anders formulieren, als die Büchereien so genutzt werden. Und inzwischen gibt es einige Organisationen, die mal Listen führen, wie viele Schulen das betreffen und wie viele Bücher da mittlerweile schon diskutiert werden. Und diese Library Association hat 1597 Bücher auf der Liste, gegen die irgendwelche Vorwürfe erhoben wurden. Von wem auch immer. Dann irgendwann gemündet bei den Eltern, die das dann in diesen Board Meetings und so weiter aufwerfen. Und jetzt ist die große Frage der Amerika, wie geht man damit um? Denn eigentlich ist man ja der Raum, in dem diskutiert werden soll, aber doch nicht so, kann man sich da jetzt verschließen oder nicht. Und dieser Text, den ich da wirklich für diejenigen, die es interessiert, wirklich zum Nachlesen empfehlen möchte, weil da eben nicht nur diese persönlichen Geschichten, der konkret Mitarbeiterinnen vor allem thematisiert wird, sondern da wird auch mal aufgezählt, wie viele lokale Parlamente sich da mittlerweile einmischen und einfach Gesetze machen. Oder eben, wie viele Gerichte schon angerufen worden, um über Freedom of Information Act, also wo dann einfach erzwungen wird, dass Informationen herausgegeben werden, wo nämlich diese Bücherliste genommen wird und dann geschaut wird, wir möchten zum einen wissen, in welchen Büchereien, in welchen Schulbibliotheken gibt es denn dieses Buch? Und dann, wie heißen denn die Mitarbeiterinnen? Also wo die so richtig unter Druck gesetzt werden. Naja, das ist ganz, ganz schlimm da.
Und in gewisser Weise ja auch ein Anachronismus. Wenn man jetzt zum einen diese Diagnosen hat, die jungen Leute lesen nicht mehr und die gehen schon gar nicht in die Schulbibliothek, wenn dann laden die sich irgendwas aufs iPhone runter und lesen es da. Also jetzt sagt man hier, wir müssen da unbedingt mal diesen Kulturkampf gegen die Bücher führen. Das erinnert ja an solche Debatten so 50er, 60er Jahre, welches Buch darf in der Bibliothek des Priesterseminars stehen? Und ist das auch dem Bichrop recht?
Ja, genau, da geht es einfach richtig zur Sache. Also die Proud Boys fahren davor. Das Problem ist dann, wenn eben solche Schoolboard Meetings sind oder auch Veranstaltungen davor, also Demonstrationen, wo dann irgendwie hier ist die Rede von einer Frau, die da in Capet, Arkansas einfach in der Demonstration so sagt, wissen sie, ich bin auch mental ein bisschen angeschlagen und ich weiß nicht, was ich machen würde, wenn ich hier Waffen hätte und so. Also wo die wirklich ganz konkret bedroht werden. Für die Mitarbeiterinnen steht es hier so im Text, ist es eben häufig eigentlich eine Frage, wie versteht man den eigenen Beruf, der jetzt so überfrachtet wird von dieser Politik? Denn eigentlich veranstaltet man ja kleine Meetings, wirbt dann auch dafür, damit die Leute kommen, um über Bücher zu reden oder was auch immer. Nur plötzlich werden diese Veranstaltungen halt total überlaufen von Menschen, die diese Veranstaltung aber dann nur missbrauchen, um ihre identitätspolitischen Anliegen da irgendwie vorzubringen. Und sie gehen ja so namentlich so durch. Also es war ein republikanischer, lokaler Abgeordneter, der in Virginia Beach diesen Freedom of Information Act Request gemacht hat, um da einfach die Leute unter Druck zu setzen. Es werden die Bundesstaaten genannt, fünf, die Gesetze machen, wo alles Mögliche denn registriert werden muss. Auch zum Beispiel neue angeschaffte Bücher. Es gibt also dann wieder ein politisches Entscheidungsgremium, das darüber befindet, was ist hier eigentlich Kunst und was ist hier politisch fragwürdig? Was darf also in der Bibliothek nicht in den Katalog aufgenommen werden und so weiter? Und es ist wirklich abenteuerlich, das zu lesen.
Vielleicht können die sich ja vernetzen mit den Chinesen.
Es ist im Grunde nicht weit weg von so einer Situation. Genau, aber eben es spielt sich und das ist ja auch das Kritische, auf so einer lokalen Ebene ab. Das macht ja auch sowieso der Bundesebene gerade total Schwierigkeiten, dass ihr da eigentlich gar nicht eingreifen kann, weil Subsidiarität gebietet halt das alles auf unterstem Level. Und dann können allenfalls noch die lokalen Local Representatives, also Landtagsabgeordnete, Stadtparlamentarier, die toben sich da einfach so richtig aus. Und naja, da lassen wir sozusagen verbrannte Erde. Es ist kein guter Zustand, alle leiden. Und es ist eben auch dieser Schulbetrieb liegt so ein bisschen brach, wenn um die Bibliothek da immer so ein Kampf geführt wird. Nicht.
Aber ich vermute mal, dass uns das hier auch noch blühen wird, vielleicht dann nicht in der Intensität, aber wenn ich daran denke, dass wir vor Corona schon in ganz vielen Städten, auch in Koblenz, solche Gesetze hatten, wie wir brauchen ein Burka-Verbot in Hallenbädern oder so. Das ist ja einfach nur Kulturkampf. Da hat wahrscheinlich nie jemand, irgendjemand mit Burka gesehen, aber man sagt, da müssen wir mal Kulturkampf machen. Und ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass das auch noch zunehmen wird, auch dann so Debatten darüber, wenn Christopher Street Day in der Stadt ist, soll dann das Rathaus die Regenbogenflagge hissen oder nicht. Diese Sachen kommen ja so langsam. Und die Medien lieben das, darüber zu berichten. Und man hat immer viele O-Töne und es ist immer was los. Man muss selbst nicht irgendwie groß recherchieren, sondern kann einfach so einsammeln und das dann in die Zeitung gießen. Ich befürchte, dass das alles zunehmen wird, weil man das endlos durchdeklinieren kann, ohne auch nur einmal weiterzukommen. Und du kennst ja meine These, es ist immer und täglich grüßt das Murmeltier. Und diese Sachen, was canceln wir, wer darf mit Treadlocks und ohne auftreten und wer sollte mit Regenbogenfahne nicht mehr und weiß ich nicht. Das ist etwas, das kann man jeden Tag wieder von neu aufführen, dieses Theater. Das haben wir ja jetzt auch schon mit diesem komischen Ballermann-Hit erfahren. Und das ist etwas, worüber dann wahnsinnig gern gesprochen wird. Und das hat zwar für die Medien dann so eine Spektakelfunktion, aber für die, die da wirklich vor Ort sind, bedeutet das dann vielleicht sogar dann nicht nur die Androhung von Gewalt, sondern auch das Erfahren von Gewalt.
Genau, das ist so die erste Zielsetzung dort, dass da viele aus diesem Beruf einfach ausgedrängt werden und nicht weiter stören oder vielleicht diese Posten sogar dann neu besetzt werden können. Also es sind natürlich hier Arkansas, Arizona, georgia, Kentucky, da kann man ja dann die Liste wahrscheinlich so fortführen, dass man wieder die gleiche Landkarte hat wie immer mit den etwas fortschrittlicheren und dann auch separatistisch angelegten Staaten wie Kalifornien und Restamerika, das hier einfach so ein bisschen auch in Schutt und Asche gelegt wird. Also in der Ansicht hoffentlich bleibt es ein amerikanisches Phänomen und schwappt nicht auch zu uns über, wobei relativ wenig von diesen wirklich hardcore ultra-identitätspolitischen Themen bislang hier angekommen sind, auch wenn Friedrich Merz immer wieder sagt, er sieht, wie in Amerika am Campus diskutiert wird und hat deswegen Angst hier. Da würde ich sagen, so schlimm ist es nicht, aber auch in Amerika ist es halt echt nicht gut, wenn man sich sowas hier ansieht.
Das ist ein bisschen gruselig. Ja, wir springen zu den Öffentlich-Rechtlichen, die selbstverständlich auch im Internet zu Hause sein müssen. Das war erst mal eine lange Frage. Sollen die das überhaupt? Natürlich und wenn, nur auf eigenen Plattformen oder auch auf fremden Plattformen wie YouTube, TikTok, Instagram. Nun wissen wir, sie sind inzwischen auf diesen Plattformen. Henning Eichler hat eine Studie vorgelegt, Journalismus in sozialen Netzwerken, ARD und ZDF im Bann der Algorithmen? Er hat sich dafür mit sehr vielen Leuten getroffen, aus verschiedenen öffentlich-rechtlichen Sendern. Er hat sich die Formate angesehen, aber er analysiert jetzt nicht die Formate, sondern will wissen, warum wird das gesendet und nicht etwas anderes? Also wir bleiben heute eigentlich die ganze Zeit bei diesem Thema. Wie programmiert man etwas? Wer programmiert hier wen? Also erst mal war die und ZDF, das waren die Programmmacher. Die sagten, eine Nachrichtensendung ist 15 Minuten lange, ein Beitrag 90 Sekunden, ein O-Ton darf nicht länger als 30 Sekunden sein, all das. Nun haben wir Plattformen, die sagen, ja am besten sind 60 Sekunden Videos. Und die nächsten Monate sagen, am besten sind 30 Sekunden. Oder lieber mal Text weglassen, mehr Musik. Und wer programmiert jetzt eigentlich wen? Wir wissen, dass es dem Algorithmus gefällt, ist eine vielsagende Begründung in einem der Interviews für die intensive Interaktion der Redaktion mit dem Publikum. So heißt es ziemlich am Anfang schon dieser Studie. Und dem geht er jetzt also nach. Inwieweit ist das denn so? Wir wissen, auch die Öffentlich-Rechtlichen setzen sich den Quotendruck aus, obwohl sie das gar nicht müssten, glauben dann immer zu wissen, was das Publikum will und was man hier schon mal vorab sagen kann zu dieser Studie. Der Quotendruck ist jetzt noch spezialisierter, aber er ist auch zugleich noch höher geworden. Er beginnt tatsächlich diese Studie mit so einem fast szenischen Einstieg. Was lief gut, was lief nicht so gut, was haben wir heute vor? Die Redaktion bespricht den Stand der aktuellen Produktion und blickt auf die frisch ausgespielten Beiträge zurück. Unverzichtbare Aspekte der morgenrunde sind Zahlen und Zielgruppen. Welche Reichweite hat der Post von gestern? Kann der prominente YouTuber Finn Kliemann gewonnen werden, an einem Beitrag mitzuwirken, damit der mehr Nutzerinnen erreicht? Also das ist noch vor dem Kliemannskandal. Trifft der geplante Beitrag zum Thema Adoption die Zielgruppe? Schließt das Thema möglicherweise zu vielen Nutzer aus und und und? Also ist er bei vielen unterwegs. Hier das war jetzt eine Impression von Deutschland 3000. Ist dann auch bei Y-Kollektiv. Die erste Minute des Films muss noch YouTube-typischer werden. Um die Aufmerksamkeit der Nutzerinnen zu wecken, ist man sich da in einer Redaktion sicher. Für die vorliegende Studie gibt es 273 öffentlich-rechtliche Angebote auf den verschiedenen Plattformen. Davon entstehen 75 exklusiv für soziale Netzwerke. Das heißt, das sind also Sachen, die nicht nochmal ausgespielt werden im Fernsehen. Und das gibt es nicht nur in Form von Funk, sondern auch hat die Tagesschau Beiträge, die dann nur für TikTok zum Beispiel bestimmt sind. Und nun wird sehr viel Methodisches erklärt. Es wird auch nochmal die Plattformen werden erklärt, wie sie funktionieren oder wie wenig wir eigentlich über ihre Funktionsweise wissen. Immer nur so im Dunkeltappen, wie funktionieren eigentlich die Algorithmen? Wie müssen wir uns also darauf anpassen? Das überspringen wir jetzt mal, um zu so ein paar Aussagen zu kommen, die Henning Eichler einfangen konnte und die oft dann anonym sind. Also indem er einfach nur mal so Redakteure befragt hat, wie sie das so eigentlich sehen. Erstmal noch, bevor ich zu den Aussagen komme, die Zentralredaktion von Funk hat, das wusste ich auch nicht, eine eigene Business Intelligence aufgebaut, mit der über alle bespielten Plattformen hinweg Daten gesammelt und ausgewertet werden. Diese werden in der Funkzentrale in Mainz, auf einem Großbildschirm genannt Dashboard, eindrucksvoll dargestellt. Für alle Mitarbeiterinnen ist ersichtlich, wie sich Formate quantitativ entwickeln. Die Zahlen haben direkten Einfluss auf die Inhalte. Wenn die Reichweite hinter den gesteckten Erwartungen bleiben, wird das Angebot überprüft, inhaltlich weiterentwickelt und bei anhaltendem Misserfolg eingestellt. Also man hat den Quotendruck die ganze Zeit vor Augen und nennt das jetzt modernes Fernsehen oder modernes Medienmachen. Ich will hier nochmal hinzufügen, weil dann immer gesagt wird, ja, aber du bist ja auch bei YouTube. Bis heute und ich bin jetzt seit elf Jahren da, habe ich noch nie diese Statistik ausgewertet von YouTube. Das einzige, was ich sehe, ist, wenn ich ein Video veröffentliche, ist auf dieser Startseite, wie viele Leute das letzte Video gesehen haben und wie lange sie dabei geblieben sind. Und mehr kriege ich von all dem nicht mit. Habe ich niemals reingeguckt. Ich habe einfach immer nur das gemacht, was ich machen wollte. Und das kann ich auch nur jedem empfehlen. Aber hier, die machen natürlich, nehmen alles mit, analysieren alles aus. Seit der Gründung von Funk hat das Netzwerk rund 150 Formate entwickelt und produziert, von denen etwa 80 nach kurzen Publikationsdauer und aus unterschiedlichen Gründen wieder beendet wurden. Also da wird wahrscheinlich der Quotendruck dann sehr stark gewesen sein, weil man natürlich auch solchen Formaten überhaupt keine Chance gibt. Die müssen dann innerhalb von drei Wochen entweder zünden oder es muss schon wieder irgendwas verändert werden. Meine Erfahrung ist ja auch, Konzepte gerade nicht zu verändern. Das ist auf Dauer das, was sich durchsetzt. Im Übrigen für den Neuen Zwanziger Podcast gilt das ja auch. Also wir haben da ja einen kontinuierlichen Hörer zu was. Und ich glaube, das liegt jetzt nicht, oder ich würde sagen, es liegt ganz klar daran, weil wir es nicht ändern. Aber hier geht es die ganze Zeit Konzept neu entwickeln und so. Da entstehen dann ja auch so bürokratische Apparate und viele Leute, die mit dumm Schwätzen viel Geld verdienen, die dann ja nur noch auf diesen Zahlen Voodoo bestehen. Und natürlich bleibt das Inhaltliche damit stark auf der Strecke. Zwar bestätigt man immer wieder, ja, wir haben natürlich unseren journalistischen Einspruch und so, aber man muss ja nun mal das meiste sich bei Funk ansehen. Dann weiß man ja, wo der Hase läuft, dass es da dann tatsächlich lieber darum geht, wie kriegt man noch irgendwelche Influencer irgendwo hin. Überraschend auch Facebook ist sehr wichtig. Noch immer für die Öffentlich- rechtlichen. Also für mich war das überraschend. Also ganz, ganz viele, die meisten Sachen, also wenn man sich die Verteilung öffentlich-rechtlicher, journalistischer Kanäle und Accounts in den sozialen Medien ansieht, dann ist auf Platz eins Facebook, Platz zwei Instagram, dann Twitter, dann YouTube, dann Spotify und erst dann ganz unten TikTok. Also TikTok wird vermutlich dann auch noch größer werden. Aber Facebook mit Abstand auf Platz eins hätte ich auch nicht gedacht. Aber wenn man sich diese ganzen regional Fernsehgeschichten ansieht, dann glaube ich schon, dass das sehr stark da ist. Nun kommen wir mal zu noch ein paar Interviewaussagen. Da sagt eine Person, so doof es klingt, alles in allem muss man sagen, eigentlich ist es bei uns, glaube ich, fast nichts unabhängig davon, dass es auf der Plattform TikTok landet. Weder Form, noch Inhalt, noch Thema, noch Ansprache. Das heißt, hier formt also die Plattform natürlich alles. Eine andere Person sagt, je länger man dabei ist, desto stärker geht man eben auf diese Konventionen ein. Beispielsweise je kürzer, desto besser. Am Anfang haben wir immer versucht, diese eine Minute und dann war uns irgendwann klar, wenn das Thema das irgendwie hergibt, dann ist 30 Sekunden noch besser und 20 Sekunden war noch besser. Und dann wundert man sich natürlich nach hinterher wieder, dass die Leute keine Aufmerksamkeit haben für größere Themen und für nichts zu begeistern sind, außer vielleicht für Populismus. Andere Personen sagen, da habe ich mich eigentlich fast zu 100% daran orientiert, was auf der Plattform gut funktioniert, wie das auf der Plattform auszusehen hat oder wie zumindest die Sehgewohnheiten auf der Plattform ist. Da ist wirklich eine große Orientierung auch daran gewesen, muss ich auch nicht verheimlichen, weil wir orientieren uns an dem, was da läuft und was die Leute kennen und was die gut finden und was funktioniert. Also man dupliziert eigentlich das ohnehin schon vorhandener, willst dann ein bisschen aufhübschen oder ein bisschen journalistisch aufwerten, aber mehr geschieht dann eigentlich nicht. Und das ist das für mich so tragische dabei, dass man nicht sagt, ne, wir sind auf diesen Plattformen, wir haben diesen Quotendruck erst mal nicht. Wir können Gegenwelten aufmachen und sind so sehr überzeugt von unserer Qualität und unseren Einfällen, dass wir schon ein Publikum dafür generieren werden. Denn hier wird einfach nur darauf, also eigentlich ist das ja, die sehen ja das Publikum wie eine Katze, der man auf den Schwanz tritt. Wenn man drauf tritt, macht die Miau. Und wenn man jetzt sich so das Publikum vorstellt, dann sagt man, ja, die wollen gerne 30 Sekunden Videos, wo Leute verrückt tanzen. Jetzt sind wir die Öffentlich-Rechtlichen. Vielleicht können wir noch irgendwie eine Klimazahl mit reinbringen. Aber eigentlich machen wir mal dasselbe, weil die Leute ja so sind. Und da wäre ich dann auch wieder bei Alfie Bown, würde ich sagen, nee, man kann das Ganze auch progressiver gestalten. Klar hat man eine gewisse Limitierung in einem Medium, wie man auch in einem Podcast miteinander spricht und nicht gleichzeitig eine Interaktion oder so anbieten kann. Und eine Fernsehsendung funktioniert anders als eine Radiosendung. Aber dass man sich derart diesem algorithmischen Druck unterwirft, ist doch sehr, sehr besorgniserregend.
Vor allem, wenn man einen Funk extra gründet, weil man die alten Sehgewohnheiten im Fernsehen nicht stören möchte. Und dann verfängt man sich genau in der gleichen Sehgewohnheitsfalle wieder im Internet. Das ist ja dumm. Ja, kann man gar nicht anders sagen.
Andere Personen sagt, was so das Label von Instagram ist, das heißt hochwertige Bilder, bildgewaltige Darstellung, nicht so viele Textzeilen auf einen Bildpost machen. Daran orientieren wir uns tatsächlich sehr, weil das ja auch die Art und Weise ist, wie wir dann möglichst viele Nutzerinnen und Nutzer zu uns bekommen. Es geht auch immer nur um die Anzahl, dass irgendwas passiert. Es geht gar nicht um die Qualität, dass dann nur das mal groß aufgerufen wurde. Es gibt immer die Frage an den Kollegen, der den Inhalt entworfen hat. Wen willst du damit erreichen? Und was soll der Nutzer damit machen? Weil wir wissen, wenn der Nutzer nichts damit macht, außer reines zur Kenntnis nehmen, führt das zu einer sehr niedrigen Reichweite. Das ist etwas, was man meiner Meinung nach auf der Plattform einfach nicht lassen kann. Also es wird hier so programmiert, so journalistisch gestaltet, dass es eine Interaktion hervorrief, wo man doch sagen kann, na ja, aber es ist ja eigentlich ganz gut, wenn man es einfach mal zur Kenntnis nimmt und es einen nicht gleich in Wut zum Beispiel versetzt. Und es sind ja auch meistens die negativen Gefühle, die einen zu Interaktionen im Netz treiben. Man schreibt ja nicht hundertmal am Tag schönes Foto, toll, danke für den Hinweis, sondern es sind eher die Dinge, die einen aufregen. Andere Personen sagt, wenn dann jemand in der Themenkonferenz kommt und sagt, ich habe was total Spannendes zum Thema Umweltschutz gelesen, dann sind wir mittlerweile so auf einem Stand. Wir haben es nicht nur einmal probiert, wir haben es ziemlich oft probiert, haben gemerkt, das verfängt nicht. Nun ist es mittlerweile so, wenn es nicht ein richtiges starkes Thema ist, dann wird es auch mit dem Verweis darauf, dass es wahrscheinlich nicht funktionieren wird, auch eher abgelehnt. Also es geht ja aber jetzt nicht um das Inhaltliche, ob das Thema wirklich gut ist, sondern immer darum, ob es funktionieren wird. Es gibt dann auch Aussagen, die sagen, na ja, es ist alles gar nicht so schlimm. Und natürlich sind für uns journalistische Standards nach wie vor wichtig. Aber es überwiegt doch, so mein Eindruck, eine Aussage wie diese. Im Endeffekt ist entscheidend die Zahl der Aufrufe. Die steht bei jedem TikTok-Video öffentlich daneben. Das ist für uns eigentlich das Wichtigste, weil wir eben möglichst viele Leute erreichen wollen, weil wir eben den Eindruck haben, wir sind für viele der erste Anknüpfungspunkt bei vielen Nachrichten. Ja, aber man bleibt Anknüpfungspunkt, beziehungsweise man führt die Menschen nicht wirklich zu guten Nachrichten, zu einer ordentlichen Information, sondern das, was man macht, ist, man spielt das Spiel mit, wird aber nur deshalb auch gesehen, weil man das Spiel mitspielt. Und sobald man etwas anderes anbietet, ziehen die User nicht mehr mit. Weißt du, wo man das am wunderbarsten erleben könnte? Bei den ganzen Influencern, die irgendwann sich sagten, ja, Podcast ist auch noch so ein Ding, da kann ich auch noch ein paar Leute rüberziehen. Und da wäre doch gut, wenn ich da Leute interviewe, so Klimaforscher und sowas fällt einem dann ein. Und da musst du dir mal so Aufrufe, wenn das bei YouTube dann zu sehen ist, ansehen. Die haben dann 500, 600 Aufrufe, Leute mit einem Millionenprofil bei Instagram. Weil einfach diese Community nur Bikini-Fotos oder so ein Kram sehen will. Die sagen nicht, ach toll, und jetzt setzen sie sich auch noch mit dem Klimawandel auseinander. Und ähnlich ist es auch bei diesen ganzen TikTok-Formaten. Also es ist ja sehr, sehr traurig, irgendwie zu sehen, wie sehr da nur auf diese Zahlen geguckt wird. Ich könnte jetzt noch viele weitere Beispiele anführen, aber ich empfehle da mal in diese Studie reinzulesen. Nicht sehr lange, 116 Seiten. Man muss das nicht komplett durcharbeiten, aber dass man mal so einen Eindruck gewinnt. Es ist da sicherlich nicht alles verloren. Das will ich nicht sagen, aber es ist sehr traurig, weil ich ja ein Anhänger des Öffentlich-Rechtlichen bin, dass man sich so den Plattformen unterwirft und eigentlich nur das macht, was die Influencer schon zu Genüge tun.
Ja, man hätte immer gedacht, sie machen es jetzt besser und so. Klar behaupten sie auch von sich, es ist ja alles besser. Aber vom Prinzip her ist jetzt doch alles nur diese große Soße, die man ein bisschen mit umrührt, wenn man aus einem Löffel reinhalten will. Nun gut, Elliot Page ist euphorisch. Der Text heißt Die Euphorie des Elliot Page. Es ist selbst formuliert, wie auch immer. Es wurde übersetzt aus einem englischen Text und bei Esquire erschien, eine Publikation, die ich soweit auch nicht kenne. Und wir folgen einfach mal diesem Selbstgespräch eines Transmanns. Wir kennen Umbrella Academy, das kenne ich jetzt nicht, aber dafür gab es Oscar-Nominierung wahrscheinlich. Oder wie auch immer, das hier gemeint ist. Ach nee, das ist der Film, der jetzt aktuell oder die Serie, die aktuell auf Netflix läuft und hier noch mal genannt wurde. Also, wahrscheinlich der berühmteste Transmann der Welt, das kann sein. Und es war eben unbeschreiblicher Hass, der da ganz lange eine Rolle spielte. Was mich ein bisschen gewundert hat, weil warum und so sie war doch nun eine ganz unschuldig und deswegen wurde sie ja auch gebucht damals und jetzt als Mann auch nicht auffälliger würde ich sagen. Also wirklich komisch, wo es dann immer eine Rolle spielt, aber umso lehrreicher dann, dass man es da mal hört. Was habe ich durch meine Geschlechtsangleichung, nicht Umwandlung, Angleichung gelernt? Ich kann gar nicht sagen, was es für eine Freude ist, sich endlich selbst zu sehen. Denn jetzt, wie sie verändert aussieht, oder er verändert aussieht. Aber in meinen Augen sehe ich endlich aus, wie ich selbst. Wenn wir immer hier so über Trans-Personen reden, dann geht es ja häufig darum zu fragen, wo wollen sie denn hin? Welches Geschlecht ist ihnen denn genehm? Und dann bietet man ihnen ja auch noch ganz viele an. Das ist ja häufig in der Realität ganz anders, dass man eigentlich ziemlich genau weiß, in welcher Form man leben möchte. Dann ist es sehr häufig männlich oder weiblich. Es ist gar nicht so diese Vogue-Debatte, die sich da so niederschlägt, bei denen die tatsächlich betroffen sind. Aber es wird immer ein bisschen ausgeblendet, dass man ja auch irgendwo herkommt. Also man entscheidet sich ja nicht für ein anderes Geschlecht, sondern auch gegen eins, das man schon hat. Und das wird irgendwie relativ... Klar, der Leidensdruck wird thematisiert, aber es wird wenig da so in die Tiefe gegangen, um das nochmal zu beschreiben. Dass man die Beziehung zu sich selber in dieser Form gar nicht hat. Und ich finde es auch immer noch ein bisschen unverständlich, ehrlicherweise so darüber nachzudenken. Denn wer man selber ist, das weiß man ja doch ziemlich gut. Aber wenn man sich im Spiegel so gar nicht sehen kann, und zwar wegen etwas, dass man auch gar nicht so leicht ändern kann, also wo jetzt Mode oder was auch immer gar keine große Abhilfe, sondern wenn dann nur so ein kleines Vertuschen darstellt, das ist hier schon ganz interessant dargestellt.
Das ist ganz gut, dieser Punkt. Das erinnert mich jetzt wieder an dieses Lied, das ich mal zitiert habe von Romy Haag, die blaue Gitarre, auch sehr spät diese Geschlechtsangleichung vorgenommen. Das war also in den 80er Jahren. Und da gibt es dieses Lied, das Klaus Hoffmann für Romy Haag geschrieben hat. Und da gibt es auch diese Passage, also sie geht zurück zu dem Haus, wo sie herkommt und sieht da in dem Spiegel, aber nicht mehr die Person von früher. Und das Lied endet dann damit. Und wenn der Wind von Holland weht, dann wird mir wieder klar, dass was ich heute sehen kann, schon immer in mir war. Also es geht wirklich auch darum, dass man es sehen kann im Spiegel, dass man sich dann sehen kann.
Genau, diese Sichtbarkeit. Und er beschreibt es hier, endlich Teil der Welt zu sein und nicht mehr permanent den Drang zu haben, aus dem eigenen Körper entfliehen zu wollen. Also da steckt ja beides drin, die Welt und der eigene Körper. Das ist irgendwie ganz interessant beobachtet, denn es ging immer eine nie endende Angst und Nervosität damit einher, sich nicht zu Hause im eigenen Körper zu fühlen. Ich kam während der Highschool jedes Jahr auf eine neue Schule. Das ist ja auch eine interessante Geschichte, wenn du da gar keine Konstanz in deiner Welterfahrung hast, sondern jedes Mal immer wegen Mobbing, also das spielt immer eine wahnsinnig große Rolle, zermürbend und hier ein interessanter Satz. Mobbing verändert einen so tiefgreifend, dass man später wahnsinnig viel wieder verlernen muss. Das ist ja auch häufig so eine therapeutische Auftrag, dass man aus diesen Mustern ausbricht und eigentlich verlernt. Also in Vergangenheit lässt, was man so mit sich geschleppt hat, statt jetzt unbedingt Neues lernen zu müssen. Am Ende muss nicht mal mehr jemand etwas sagen, und man spürt die Verachtung dennoch. Also da ist ja dann auch immer die Frage, kann man in die Köpfe des anderen reingriechen? Nein, wenn man überinterpretiert und fehlinterpretiert, dann vielleicht auch viel, sodass man sich in so einer einen hassenden Welt sieht, die vielleicht gar nicht so sehr hasst, aber weil Einzelne immer wieder Anlass geben, in die Richtung zu denken, dass sich da wirklich das so niederschlägt. Na ja, hat dann jedenfalls früh so einen Mark gehabt im Leben, der die eigenen Gefühle und den Schmerz so ein bisschen teilen konnte und keine Kompromisse gemacht hat bei der Frage, wer man ist. Also es war dann doch relativ früh so mit engen Freundschaften begleitet. Und er kann sich noch an das Jahr erinnern, in dem im Sport nach Geschlechtern aufgeteilt wurde, selten so verstört und extrem verzweifelt ist er gewesen. Also als es dann in der Schule ging so jetzt Mädchen hier, Jungs da. Ich glaube nicht, dass Jungs hier mitspielen dürfen, sagten dann einzelne Schiedsrichter. Also ist dann auch so eine belanglose Kommunikation, die dann aber auf der anderen Seite so krass ankommt. Und 2014 hatte ich mich als homosexuell geoutet, aber das war ganz anders, also etwas anderes als dann zwar homosexuell, also zu wissen, dass die Menschen wissen, dass man homosexuell lebt und trotzdem immer noch im falschen Körper zu stecken. Und dann spielt immer wieder dieser Hass und die Boshaftigkeit und die Unerbittlichkeit eine sehr große Rolle. Und heute selbst als Mann schreibt er mir, tun CIS-Männer leid, denn sie leben mit Erwartung an das männliche Geschlecht und damit so eingeschränkt und unterdrückt, dass sie eigentlich jedem Mann so eine Art Coming-out so ein bisschen wünscht. Ja, dass man einfach mal so ausbrechen kann. Keine Ahnung, inwieweit das jetzt so Beobachtung ist, die irgendwie dann vielleicht nicht flächendeckend nachvollzogen werden muss oder auch andere Gedanken noch mal spielen.
Naja, ich denke, diese Entwicklung von Proud Boys, Pickup Artist und all das, Jordan Peterson Anhänger ist ja auch nicht nur jetzt für viele, die von denen Hass oder was abbekommen, problematisch, sondern man muss es ja auch als eine Art Hilferuf sehen. Also man kann es auch als ein Symptom sehen für eine große Verzweiflung, dass man offenbar doch mit der eigenen Identität, die man bis aufs Messer verteidigen will, die männliche, heterosexuelle, wo man alles als Gefahr ansieht, was dann zum Beispiel sich darin ausdrückt, dass man Transpersonen attackiert oder so, dass das ja ein Zeichen dafür ist, dass man sich dann offenbar überhaupt nicht seiner selbst sicher ist. Und vielleicht vieles, was man begehrt oder wünscht, nicht artikulieren kann, geschweige denn ausleben kann. Nicht in dem Sinne von Outing, wie eigentlich sind die alle schwul oder eigentlich sind die alle Transpersonen, sondern dass auch hier offenbar selbstgemacht oder von der Gesellschaft erwartet. Und sicherlich ist das nicht nur durch eine männliche Kodierung, sondern auch eine gesamtgesellschaftliche, also auch Frauen eingeschossen, die dafür sorgt, dass ein Mann so und so zu sein hat. Und das erzeugte einen extremen Druck, der dann über das Ventil Hass vielleicht auch sich dann ausdrückt.
Genau. Elliot Page wünscht sich hier grundsätzlich mehr zugestattene Sensibilität, dass Männer mit ihrer ernsthaft gefühlten Sensibilität mehr ins Kommunikative treten dürfen, ohne sich dann gleich wieder Kommentare einzufangen, dass man halt da irgendwie weinerlich oder was auch immer sei. Da hat dann auch die Metrosexualität von David Paik wahrscheinlich wenig beigetragen, obwohl das ja in so eine Richtung ging, sich dann auch mal zu schmücken und so weiter, den Körper mal anders zu benutzen. Elliot hat jedenfalls festgestellt, noch nie so viel Sport getrieben in meinem Leben. Endlich fühlt es sich richtig an, in den eigenen Körper, ich würde sagen, zu investieren oder ihn überhaupt mal hier zu nutzen. Heute ist er geradezu süchtig. Nach diesem Gefühl, wirklich mit meinem Körper zu arbeiten, finde ich auch interessant, nach so viel Schauspielerei und so weiter. Dass er jetzt so ganz im Privaten irgendwie angekommen ist und es total aufregend findet, Muskelmasse aufzubauen, ist auch eine Beeindruckung, das Sixpack auf dem einen Bild zu sehen.
Dein Fitnesswahn, das ist ja auch noch was. Da bin ich mal gespannt, wie das in den nächsten Jahren noch weitergeht.
Tatoos, nächster großer Punkt, der hier eine große Rolle spielt. Und zwar vor allem Namen. Namen der Initialen von Freunden, die geholfen haben. Haben es gleich auf den Körper verewigt geschafft. Erinnert sich, wie er auf einer Party war, mitgenommen von einer Freundin und an diesem Abend so viele Menschen kennengelernt hat. Also so ein Abend, der die irgendwie die ganze Welt verändert. Das heute sehr viele Namen des Abends auf dem Körper stehen. Und genau Sport, Tatoos. Nächste Runde ist hier Sex, spielt auch eine große Rolle. Liebe kann bedeutendig zu fragen, werde ich fähig sein, jemanden zu lieben, der nicht perfekt ist und wird diese Person jemanden lieben können, der nicht perfekt ist, nämlich mich? Das ist auch eine interessante Frage, wie vorhin schon Sehnsüchter und so weiter. Oder irgendwo mal so eine pragmatische Linie einzuziehen. Und dann zum Mode. Es ist nur ein ganz kleiner Satz, aber den fand ich natürlich gerade auch durch diesen Wolfgang Joop Satz, der Jugend steht das weiße T-Shirt am besten. Erst danach braucht man alles, was Alter und Gewicht verschleiert. Und da ist Gewicht bei Wolfgang Joop schon eine Rolle. Das habe ich nicht wieder reingebracht. Elliot Page sagt hier, was mich glücklich macht, es ist Sommer, es ist heiß draußen und ich trage nur ein weißes T-Shirt, das mir passt. Und das ist ja in dieser Wolfgang Joop Dimension der Gipfel des Zufriedenheitsgefühls, wenn man sich im weißen T-Shirt selber wohlfühlt. Denn dann braucht man erstmal die Mode noch nicht. Also in der Ansicht gar nicht so schlecht. Naja, und dann klingt es aus mit nochmal diesen großen Beschreibungen der Unzufriedenheit. Das kann man sich immer gar nicht vorstellen. Juno, so ein krasser Mega-Welterfolg. Ich habe ihn jetzt auch nicht mehr vor dem Kopf, so vor den Augen, aber ich weiß, das war ein Mega-Erfolg und hat irgendwie eine Schwangerschaft.
Das war ja so ein Independent-Film, Außenseitertum. Also das war ja schon was, was auch so eine kleine Hollywood-Revolution zumindest war, dass es mal eben nicht diese Hochglanz-Ästhetik war.
Und er wünscht sich heute, dass die Menschen begreifen, dass mich das alles damals fast umgebracht hat. Also diese Art der Aufmerksamkeit und nicht damit umgehen zu können, weil man sich gerne eigentlich anders zeigen wollte. Und selbst bei Inception, die ganze Zeit im Hotel, dann die Szene gedreht und wieder zurück ins Hotel, sich bloß nicht der Welt ausgesetzt. Drehbücher lesen muss mega anstrengend gewesen sein, obwohl heute das große Hobby ist, einfach im weißen T-Shirt da sitzen und irgendwas weglesen. Essstörungen, starke Depressionen, Angststörungen, Panik machen, Schmerzen, Schmerzen, Schmerzen, Schmerzen, Schmerzen. Ich schaffte es nicht mehr, Drehbücher zu lesen. Lesen ist einer meiner liebsten Beschäftigungen, aber ich konnte es nicht mehr. Da kann man ja dieses Leiden mal so ablesen. Und noch ein wichtiger, interessanter Körperbezug. Ich konnte mir nicht vorstellen, als Frau zu altern. So, dieses gerade jetzt hier noch so, okay, irgendwie, aber es muss eine Abhilfe geben. Ich will so nicht altern. Das ist auch so ein Gefühl, dass man gar nicht kennt, irgendwie als relativ sich normal einschätzende Person. Naja, es ist ein sehr langer Text, der auch noch mal so ein bisschen Cancel Culture und so weiter. Auch aus dieser, die Leute wissen ja gar nicht, was Cancel Culture ist und so, was man, wo man hier denkt, ja stimmt, muss man über das Wort Cancel nochmal anders nachdenken. Und Kinder? Nein, Kinder spielen ja keine Rolle. Vielleicht, wenn er jemanden kennenlernt, der schon Kinder hat, könnte er sich vorstellen, dann mal Kinder zu adoptieren. Aber im Grunde ist es dieses, ich versuche mal diesen Satz genau zu finden. Kinder? Nein, ich habe das Gefühl, dass ich mich schon so viel um mich selbst kümmern musste. Also es steckt so eine Erleichterung, ich habe es erst mal geschafft. Das spüre ich gerade auch. Drei Kinder, das jüngste wird jetzt sechs und eingeschult. Damit hat man schon mal so ein bisschen was absolviert, wo man sich nicht unbedingt denkt, oh ja, ich will noch mal so ein Jährling, so ein richtig kleines Baby, das nur rumschreit, dem man so gar nichts richtig abhelfen kann, sondern nur so Büchern oder aus Erfahrung nachblättert. Und dann hoffen wir, dass es funktioniert. Und dann wiegt man sie und singt ihnen was vor. Aber es ist im Grunde einmal das Leben kennengelernt mit Kindern, die älter als sechs sind, muss man sagen. Ja, dann fahre ich lieber Taron, als mich da noch mal durchzuquälen. Und so scheint das hier auch zu sein. Ich habe mich jetzt erst mal genug um mich gekümmert. Haken dran, nächste Etappe. Also sehr interessanter Text, wo man nochmal, weil so viel gerade vorhin auch über Beziehungen gesprochen wurde, die Beziehung zu einem selbst, die kann man hier nochmal so richtig auf die Probe stellen, wenn man sowas liest, ob man nicht doch eigentlich ein super glückliches Leben führt und wie es anderen so geht. Also seltene Einblicke, die dann eben wie vorhin schon gesagt, so ein bisschen hervorgehoben werden, weil man sich relativ sicher sein kann, dass alle anderen Bedürfnisse, materiell bedingt und so, erstmal geregelt sind bei solchen dann doch ja wohlhabenden Schauspielern und so. Naja, Elliot Page kommt also so langsam jetzt aus der Reserve und mal gucken. Die Bilder, die man hier sieht, gerade weil man sie von früher noch erkennt, das ist schon interessant, das dann mal in dem Film irgendwie zu sehen, was auch immer für eine Rolle da ist.
Ja, der Film ist natürlich ganz interessant, weil er die Zeit konserviert. Und das ist dann auch nochmal ja diese interessante Frage des Alters. Das hatten wir schon bei dem Tom-Coo-Film. Noch eine Anmerkung zu diesem weißen T-Shirt-Ding von Wolfgang Jupp. Es stimmt natürlich, aber das trifft ja auch auf wenige Leute zu, wo man das wirklich sagen kann. Es hat ja nicht nur mit Jugend und all dem zu tun, sondern man muss auch irgendwie Glück gehabt haben. Übrigens wird ja bei Gewicht auch sehr oft vergessen, wie sehr doch Gewicht auch mit Veranlagung zu tun hat.
Stimmt.
Und wie sehr Körper in welche Richtung auch immer tendieren. Also sicherlich nicht zu einem Übergewicht, das einen krank macht oder so. Aber es gibt durchaus Leute, die einfach dazu neigen, fülliger zu sein als andere oder auch sehr viel schwieriger es abbauen können. Also ich muss vielmehr auf mein Essen, auf meine Ernährung achten. Als es z.B. mein Vater tut, der alles in sich reinschaufeln kann und trotzdem kein Gramm zunimmt. Und ich dann immer denke, das gibt es doch gar nicht. Wenn ich das essen würde, dann würde ich ganz anders aussehen. Und gerade die Mode ermöglicht ja auch, dass die Formen, die nicht schlank sind, ganz anders und sehr interessant zur Geltung gebracht werden können. Also gerade auch diese ganzen japanischen Modemacher. Das hat ja auch Lagerfeld zu seinen korpulenteren Zeiten erahnen können. Gleiten natürlich einen fülligen Körper ganz anders und lassen auch diese Mode wiederum ganz anders zur Geltung kommen. Kurzum, ich glaube, man muss da erstmal betrachten, dass das auch natürlich eine Ästhetik ist. Und es gibt auch Leute, die einfach sich nicht wie daraus machen. Also, die auch sich aus Frisuren oder so nichts machen. Oder sonst modisch sagen sie es mir einfach egal. Und ich bin nun jemand, der lieber noch mal zurückläuft und noch mal in den Spiegel guckt. Aber ich kann das auch durchaus verstehen und habe auch Leute in meinem Umfeld, die genauso draußen sind, die sagen, nö, interessiert mich eigentlich gar nicht. Aber die Zeit, die du da im Bad verbringst, in der Zeit kann man noch was Interessantes lesen. Ich glaube, das ist sehr wichtig, auch gerade weil wir diese extrem vielen Social-Media-Seiten haben, die so auf Körper sind. Also Instagram ist der Körper. Das ist nicht, ich habe hier mal ein Text für euch, sondern es ist wirklich der Körper TikTok, ganz extrem, der Körper in Bewegung. Und deswegen glaube ich, ist es ganz gut, wenn man auch mal wieder in und wieder sieht oder erkennt, nein, der Körper ist jetzt auch nicht alles. Denn das ist ja das Tragische in gewisser Weise auch, wenn man nicht wie Dorian Gray nur auf dem Bild alt hat und sonst nicht mehr bleibt, dass man natürlich älter wird. Und jetzt kann man sagen, ja, man kann auf die eine oder andere Weise alt werden und den Körper in Form halten. Aber dennoch ist es so, dass der 21-jährige sportliche Körper am Ende der Attraktivere ist im Vergleich mit dem 51-jährigen sportlichen Körper.
Genau, ich will mich auch selbst noch mal verteidigen, bevor wieder Mails kommen, weil ich heute mehrfach über den Körper und weiter. Der Körper, und das habe ich sehr ausführlich reflektiert, und es gilt vor allem auch für mein Gefühlsleben. Also damit meine ich jetzt vor allem der Körper der Frau, spielt so lange eine Rolle, wie man nichts anderes hat außer den sichtbaren Körper. Sobald die ersten Sätze gesprochen sind, liegt der erste Eindruck, den man über das Visuelle hat, bei mir auch sehr weit bis hin zu vergraben. Also in der Ansicht unterstellt mir bitte keine falsche, nur das Ding ist, wenn ich durch die Stadt laufe und Frankfurt am Main ist eine große, dichte Stadt, da sehe ich sehr viele Menschen, mit denen ich kein Wort rede. Also da bleibt nur so ein Körpereindruck. Und ja, ich achte schon so ein bisschen drauf. Also es interessiert mich einfach, wie sehen Menschen aus? Und ich rechne auch Körpergewicht in so viele Kalorien um und stelle mir vor, wie das in Essen aussieht, was da so rein investiert wurde in den ein oder anderen Körper. Also ich gehe da schon all in.
Diese Rechnung, die will ich aber jetzt gleich auch mal unterlaufen. Dadurch, dass ich sagen würde, da bin ich ja auf der besten Seite, denn ich mache ja ganz wenig Sport. Das heißt, ich verbrenne wenig Kalorien, führe aber auch wenig zu. Während du wahrscheinlich viele Kalorien zuführst, die du dann verbrennst. Also wenn wir da mal das Essen aufstapeln, da sehe ich aber besser bei aus.
Genau. Und da spielt aber die Gesamtbilanz eine große Rolle, dass ich dann auch denke, da hat aber jemand, wie du sagst, viel gegessen und auch viel dafür getan, es wieder umzuwandeln. Also keine Ahnung, das ist so mein kleiner Fable, den ich da so habe, deswegen achte ich auch bei mir ein bisschen drauf. Heißt aber nicht, dass ich Personen darauf reduziere, vor allem nicht, wie gesagt, wenn es über so einen ersten visuellen, man läuft echt nur aneinander vorbei in der Stadt und dann, wen soll es jucken? Ich gucke ja da nicht mit gehobenen Augenbrauen oder so, sondern es interessiert mir einfach. In der Ansicht schreibt gerne Mails, aber ja.
Nein, wir müssen, man muss es, wenn gesellschaftlich, natürlich sehen und auch einfach sagen, dass die Lebensmittelindustrie auch wirklich ganz viel Schlechtes verbreitet. Und damit ist nicht nur gemeint, dass es schlecht für das Gewicht ist, sondern auch für die Knochen und sonst was. Und auch da müsste eine viel größere Politisierung stattfinden. Aber das endet in Deutschland Debatten über Essen beim Veggie Day oder so ein Kram. Und das müsste dann gibt's mal so was wie Zuckersteuer oder so was wird man debattiert. Aber eigentlich müsste das auch viel stärker in Angriff genommen werden. Plus die Verantwortung, die Verantwortung, die wir für unsere Nahrung haben in Bezug auf die andere Welt, die dann keine Nahrung hat. Also das ist ja auch immer das mit dem mit dem Hunger können. Können wir den Hunger besiegen und so? Und bei uns stehen die hunderttausend Keks Packungen im Regal. Und da wird nicht eine von weggenommen, weil man sagt, wir lassen jetzt mal diese Keks Produktion, weil wir Brot herstellen für weiß ich nicht, welches Land. Also das ist, glaube ich, so ein generelles Thema, was nochmal politisiert werden soll. Ich zähle jetzt neuerdings immer so Krawatten, wenn ich nichts zu tun habe. Ich gucke, wer trägt noch Krawatte? Und das ist ein sehr einfaches Zellen. Man kommt meistens nicht in einen zweistelligen Bereich.
Jeder hat seine kleine Macke. Und du hast genau das richtige Schlusswort gefunden zu diesem Thema. Sehr gut. Mehr Politisierung wagen.
Ich will ganz kurz vorstellen, es gibt ein Erzählungsband bei Surkamp Schienen von Magda Lena Schrefel. Sie ist eine Autorin, die mit Erzählungen kommt, die sehr viel von der Arbeit handeln. Sie hat in Wien studiert, in Leipzig studiert und dieser Band brauchbare Menschen erzählt von Menschen, die arbeiten zum Beispiel als Sicherheitspersonal an Flughäfen oder die als Arbeitsmigranten aus Ländern wie Polen nach Deutschland kommen. Es wird aber auch erzählt von einer Beziehung zum Beispiel zwischen Vater und Tochter. Und auch da geht es um diese Frage des brauchbaren Menschen. Inwieweit man sich eigentlich braucht. Also man kann diese Frage der brauchbaren Menschen natürlich unter der Verwertungslogik betrachten. Das tun einige Erzählungen. Aber auch dieses Welche Menschen brauche ich eigentlich? Und zunächst mal würde man sagen, ja, der Vater steht einem ja sehr nah. Und nun ist es hier eine ganz besondere Beziehung, die in einer Geschichte geschildert wird. Und zwar bekommt die Tochter von ihrem Vater in unregelmäßigen Abständen immer wieder Anrufe. Der Vater weiß aber auch gar nicht so recht, was mit der Tochter jetzt reden. Sie sehen sich so gut wie nie, höchstens mal bei irgendwelchen Trauerfeiern oder so. Und dann ruft der Mann und sagt, hallo bist du das? Ja, ich bin es. Steve Jobs ist gestorben, der Apple Typ. Kannst du dir das vorstellen? So war es am 5. Oktober. Am 1. Dezember ruft er an. Hast du schon gehört? Was jetzt genau? Christa Wolf ist tot. Ich habe mal ein Buch von ihr gelesen, aber bei der Stasi war die auch, oder? Also er sucht immer irgendeinen Anlass, die Tochter anzurufen. Und es ist immer, dass irgendjemand verstirbt. Und es ist recht wahllos. Also manchmal ist es dann wirklich noch jemand, wo er einen Bezug zu hatten, ein Musiker, den er gehört hat. Aber eigentlich ist es nur dieser komische Anlass. Und es werden immer diese Telefonate, also es ist eine kurze Geschichte, werden so kurz geschildert. Manchmal ist es aber dann auch wirklich jemand aus der Familie, die Großmutter ist gestorben. Dann reagiert man doch noch mal anders darauf. Es sind immer ganz kurze Gespräche. Und ich glaube, das, was sie hier schildert, ist etwas, was viele nachvollziehen können. Gerade auch mit Leuten, die vielleicht die Familie verlassen für Studium und dann höchstens zu Weihnachten zurückkommen. Und dann gibt es diese komische Kommunikation via Telefon, weil man miteinander ja eng verwandt ist, aber so richtig, was kann man sich sagen? Oder inwieweit ist man eigentlich dann noch verwandt? In dem Sinne, dass man sich verwandt ist im Denken, im Reden. Und sie schreibt dann hier, also die Ichhezellerin sagt, manchmal schickt mir mein Vater Bilder, Fotos, die er mit seiner Digitalkamera macht, als E-Mail-Anhang. Immer hatte mein Vater einen Fotoapparat. Vielleicht wollte er auch einmal etwas mit Bildern machen. Dafür spricht der Filmvorführer aus Weiß, den ich einmal von ihm gefunden habe. Die Bildmotive sind ein Baum im Sommer, ein Baum im Herbst, ein Baum im Winter. Der Weihnachtsbaum. Mein Vater ist noch kein alter Mann. Trotzdem weiß ich, dass er einer werden wird. Ich sehe es genau vor mir. Er wird einer dieser Männer werden, die über den Brillenrand linsend die Zungenspitze der Konzentration wegen zwischen den Lippen auf das Mini-Display ihrer Digitalkamera blicken, um dieses eine für sie so wichtige Bild zu schießen. Und er wird dabei nicht mitbekommen, dass er hinter sich Chaos anrichtet, dass wegen seiner Schritte zur Seite den Blick immer auf das Display alle ihm ausweichen müssen. Und spräche man ihn darauf an, würde er sagen, habe ich Augen auf dem Rücken? Sie schildert das, könnte man jetzt hier meinen, etwas unbarmherzig, aber die Erzählung nimmt dann doch nochmal eine andere Wendung. Ich finde, es ist tatsächlich die stärkste Erzählung in diesem Buch. Nicht alles ist für mich perfekt, aber es ist doch eine Stimme aus der jüngeren Gegenwartstliteratur, der man Gehör schenken sollte und von der wir vielleicht noch das eine oder andere vernehmen werden. Ganz interessant auch das letzte Stück hier drin, Preisrede, in der erzählt wird, was ist eigentlich die Arbeit einer Autorin? Was verdient die Autorin? Und was muss sie eigentlich noch nebenher arbeiten, um als Schriftstellerin zu arbeiten? Und ist man überhaupt Schriftstellerin, wenn man die meiste Zeit ja sich um Haus, Familie und sonst was kümmern muss, außerdem noch einen Job hat, wo man viele Stunden verbringt und eigentlich nur wenige Stunden die Woche wirklich Zeit zu schreiben hat, kann man sich dann als Schriftstellerin bezeichnen? Das sind Fragen, die hier aufgeworfen werden. Also ein interessantes Buch für die, die sich für Gegenwartssliteratur interessieren.
Sehr gut. Wie ich zum Beispiel, der ich mich neu im Literaturhaus Frankfurt als Mitglied angemeldet habe, um dann dort auch mal über Literatur zu sprechen. Zumindest einmal im Monat gibt es einen Termin, der mir bisher nicht passte. Aber irgendwann bin ich mal da. Kommen wir zu Zahlen und damit Futurama. Ich habe das nie geguckt, Simpsons auch nicht. Dort spielt es aber eine große Rolle. Mathematik. Und zur Einstimmung lese ich jetzt einen nur wenige Minuten alten Tweet vor vom Hessischen Ministerium für Wissenschaft und Kunst. Unsere Zahl der Woche ist 70. Genauer gesagt die 1970er Jahre. Bunt mit geometrischen Muster oder Prillblumen. Unter dem Titel Op, Pop, Top! präsentiert die Museumslandschaft Hessen Kassel im Schloss Wilhelmshöhe in Kassel noch bis zum 25.09.2022 typische Tapetenmuster der Zeit. Das als kleinen Service. Ich weiß nicht genau, wie sehr Altenrepublik das ist, aber es ist wirklich unglaublich.
Und ich bin jetzt auf die Überleitung gespannt.
Naja, Zahlen. Die Zahl des hessischen Ministeriums für Wissenschaft und Kurz ist 70. Bei Futurama geht es auch um Zahlen. Sie schreiben hier in Spektrum der Wissenschaften, Maron, Manon, Bischof, um genau gesehen. Der wissenschaftliche Humor hat ja durchaus schon einen Weg gefunden. The Big Bang Theory und so weiter oder wie ist das andere, dieses britische Ding da? IT-Crowd, das ist ja alles wahnsinnig bekloppt. Und in Futurama gibt es hier auch ein Zusammenspiel von Unterhaltungsfernsehen und Wissenschaft, allerdings auf die Spitze getrieben. Denn man suchte einen Spannungsboden und fand dann auch einen. Man erfand den genialen Professor Farnsworth, der eine Maschine entwickelt hatte, die Geist und Person von jeweils zwei Personen einmal miteinander vertauschen kann. Und dieses technische Angebot nehmen die attraktive Amy und dann der Farnsworth selbst an. Denn sie wollte schon immer mal einfach so viel essen, wie sie wollte, ohne auf die Figur zu achten. Das geht natürlich am besten in so einem Körper des alten Professor. Und seine Intention war auch klar, er wollte mal wieder in einem jungen frischen Körper stecken. Also wenden die beiden die Maschine an, tauschen ihre Geister und stecken jeweils im Körper des anderen. Daraufhin werden auch die anderen Figuren aufmerksam und tauschen wild hin und her. Und dann sitzt das Autorenteam von Futurama da und denkt sich, hm, die müssen wir jetzt wieder zurücktauschen. Aber wie geht denn das überhaupt? Kann ja nur jeder mit jedem einmal tauschen. So und dann stellt der eine fest, ah, Fenn Kieler, ich hab ja an Mathematik proboviert, was man halt so macht, bevor man bei Futurama Autor wird. Und dann hat er dieses Wirrwarr, das sich da aufdröselte, aufgrund von ich gehe mal Halligalli all in und schreib hier so eine Folge, auf das mathematische Problem runtergebrochen und hat dann festgestellt, dafür gibt's gar keine Lösung. Also für so Zweierpärchen, die immer nur einmal verwendet werden können. Also musste er das erstmal formalisieren und hat sich dann hingesetzt und hat sich gedacht, ich löse es einfach selbst. Und dann besteht der Text hier auch auf der Lösung und dem Weg, zeigt auch visuell aufgedröselt, also Kleid, einmal Geist, einmal Körper, Teit, Geist, Körper und so weiter, wie sie alle miteinander vertauscht sind in Pfeilen, Kreuz und Queren, wie man das wieder zurücktauschen müsste. Und die Lösung war dann am Ende zwei weitere Personen reichen aus, aber manchmal muss man bis zu neun mal hin und her tauschen, um alles wieder zustande zu kriegen. Und der eigentliche Humor, der dann in dieser Folge drinsteckte, ist, dass die Lösung, die sie angewandt haben, um die Story zu Ende zu schreiben, mathematisch korrekt ist und sie aber darüber hinaus keine wissenschaftliche Publikation zu diesen Problemen gemacht haben, sondern die wissenschaftliche Publikation zu dem vorher nicht formulierten, aber ich finde gar nicht so abwegigen Problem. Und dann die Lösung steckt tatsächlich nur in dieser Folge einfach drin. Also das muss man einfach beim Ursprungsautor, muss man einfach Futurama angucken und dann versuchen, das da nachher zu verziehen. Man hat dann Jahre später, also die Folge wurde 2010 ausgestrahlt, 2014 haben sich nochmal drei Autoren hingesetzt und auf zwölf Seiten die Lösung mathematisch korrekt, formal korrekt aufgeschrieben. Also sie ist mittlerweile publiziert, aber Futurama ist halt all in gegangen. Und da gibt es ganz interessante Texte. Die Simpsons hatten das auch schon mal. Homer stellt irgendwie fest in seiner Midlife-Kreise, dass er ja noch nie was ernsthaft und wichtiges gemacht hat. Also nimmt er sich vor, irgendein Mathematisches Problem zu lösen oder irgendwas zu erfinden. Er möchte gerne so ein Thomas Edison sein. Und dann gibt es ein Bild, wo er an einem Tafelbild steht. Und auf der Tafel steht 3987 hoch 12 plus 4365 hoch 12 ist gleich 4472 hoch 12. Und das Besondere an dieser Art Gleichung, kennt man wahrscheinlich so ein bisschen vom Satz des Pythagoras, ist, dass es für das Ergebnis keine ganze Zahl über eins gibt. Also es ist immer eine Kommazahl. Außer in diesem Fall der Ziffern, die ich gerade genannt habe, der Zahlen. Aber auch nur, wenn man sie in den Taschenrechner eingibt, der irgendwann einfach aufhört und rundet. Und deswegen eine ganze Zahl rundet, statt irgendwo sechs Stellen hinter dem Komma oder so zu holen. Und dann haben sehr viele sehr lang gegrübelt, denen das aufgefallen ist, warum Homer vor so einer Tafel steht, auf dem die einzige, die man kennt, die einzige mit Zahlen aufgefüllte Gleichung dieser Art steht, die tatsächlich ohne Kommas auskommt. Und fanden dann schon, das hat man nicht aus Spaß oder so drangeschrieben, sondern da steckt so eine gewisse Ernsthaftigkeit dahinter, weil der, wie heißt das Problem, der fermatische, der große fermatische Satz oder wie auch immer irgendwie, ein Name wurde da verewigt, der hat doch eigentlich, das ist doch, also der sagt doch eigentlich, es gibt diese ganze Zahl nicht und dann gibt sie aber plötzlich doch und dann ist es ein Rundungsfehler und so. Also es ist total verrückt, wie viel Humor dann doch immer wieder da so reinrutscht, ohne dass das auch so erklärt wird. Also hier bei Futurama, die publizieren das dann einfach nicht, sondern senden das einfach nur so als Folge und jeder, der sich da reinkniet, seht, oh krass, die haben das ja echt korrekt gemacht und so. Und bei den Simpsons war einfach nur das Tafelbild, da hat auch keiner jemals was dazu gesagt. Na ja, ist ganz witzig. Kann man hier nochmal. Ich weiß nicht genau, warum es jetzt im Juli hier Thema war bei Spektrum der Wissenschaft, aber ich fand es irgendwie ganz witzig, dass man da nochmal kurz einen Blick in die, passt ja auch zu heute, wo wir so viel über Drehbücher und so weiter sprachen, wo man das nochmal unterbringen konnte.
Ja, das sind, glaube ich, auch so minimal subversive, dann von Drehbuchautoren oder wem auch immer, dass man sagt, das exerzieren wir jetzt da mal durch. Und das finde ich auch sehr reizvoll, dass man in der Kunst doch diese Freiheit hat, auch das zu tun. Also das ist eigentlich das Interessante, dass man sowas auch da hineinlegen kann.
Ja, vor allem mit Mathematik, wo es echt mal heißt, okay, es ist zwar alles ausgedacht, was wir machen, aber hier gibt es echt nur einen Weg jetzt. Wir müssen die mathematische Lösung und dann muss hinter dem Ist gleich genau das stehen. Und dann ist irgendwie zack, also dass man sich selbst noch mal so krass limitiert auf so ein alternativloses Element. Und dann zack geht es aber einfach weiter. Also ist schon witzig.
Hm. Wir gehen zu den neuen Rechten. Und zwar gibt es eine Zeitschrift, die heißt Die Kehre, Zeitschrift für Naturschutz. Wir sehen hier schon, es geht also nicht um Klimaschutz, Naturschutz. Die Kehre, das ist natürlich ein Begriff, der kommt von Heidegger, also der später Heidegger. Wie gehen wir mit der Technik um? Wie gehen wir mit der Natur um? Dieser Begriff, Die Kehre, der auf Heidegger zurückgeht, bildet hier den Titel dieser vierteljährlich erscheinenden Zeitschrift, die ich jetzt hier natürlich nicht empfehle, aber die ich einmal gelesen habe, weil ich jetzt wissen wollte, wie setzen sich eigentlich neue Rechte, und das sind jetzt hier neue Rechte aus dem erweiterten Kreis von Götz Kubitschek, mit diesem Thema Umweltschutz, Naturschutz und so weiter auseinander. Und dann stellt man erst einmal fest, dass es nicht so sehr um das Klima geht, sondern um die Natur auch als Ganzes. Es geht dann darum, wie könnte man zum Beispiel einen ökologischen Ackerbau betreiben? Wie könnte man ökologisch gärtnern? Das wird aber alles immer sehr stark runtergebrochen auf das, wie könnte man jetzt also irgendwo in Sachsen wieder ein Hof aufmachen, um das jetzt mal ein bisschen plump auszudrücken. Aber solche Artikel sind da zu finden. Es geht um Betrachtung der Industrialisierung, der Forstwirtschaft. Das ist mitunter dann ideologisch gleich aufgeladen. Manchmal aber ist es auch sehr deskriptiv gehalten. Es ist jetzt nicht so, dass aus jeder Zeile einem da die neue rechte Ideologie hinüberspringt. Aber man merkt dann schon, es gibt so eine gewisse Schlagseite. Also es wird von der industriellen Nahrung und dem industriellen Körper gesprochen. Also da ist dann auch natürlich das Zucker, das im Überangebot ist und sowas Thema. Und das fängt dann auch immer so an, dass man zunächst einmal, also man kann es ja immer so selbst an sich ausprobieren. Man kann so zustimmen, ja, Zucker wird da viel eingeführt. Das sind doch süchtig machende Stoppe. Das ist gerade für Kinder problematisch und und und. Und dann kommt es aber schon auf so einer Ebene, dass man sagt, ja, dieses Wirtschaften, das wir da tun. Und man denkt, aha, ist das jetzt so eine Kapitalismus Kritik? Und dann geht es hier auch um Übergewicht und so. Und dann geht es aber in so eine Richtung, dass man dann doch eigentlich so vom gesunden Volkskörper ausgehen will. Nicht, dass das so ausgesprochen wird, aber man kann es zwischen den Zeilen lesen. Vor allem, wenn man weiß, woher die Zeltstoff kommt, wird es dann sehr viel eindeutiger gleich. selbstversorgung, Autarkie sind große Themen. Also man kann sich hier auch gut vorstellen, welche Leserschaft das jetzt erreichen soll. Der Gärtnerhof selbstversorgung, ein Weg ins Freie ist da ein Buch, das empfohlen wird und dann heißt es hier auch, in den wenigsten Fällen geht es um ein Zurück in die Natur. Wissen und Kenntnisse kann man sich aneignen, Nutzflächen trotz aller Schwierigkeiten erwerben. Wessen es Bedarf, ist letztlich die persönliche Überzeugung. Eine mögliche Ansetzung zur Umsetzung dieser Ideen ist das Gärtnerhof Konzept. Der Gärtnerhof unterscheidet sich vom klassischen Bauernhof durch seine erweiterte gärtnerische Tätigkeit. Von der klassischen Gärtnerei trennt ihn die Tierhaltung. Auf einer Betriebsfläche von 2 bis 5 Hektar soll somit nicht nur eine selbstversorgung, sondern auch ein monetäres Einkommen durch den Verkauf von überschüssigen Gemüseerzeugnissen ermöglicht werden. Es wird natürlich einige Jahre dauern, bis sich solch ein Hof finanziell trägt und eine wirkliche selbstversorgung der ihn bewohnenden Familie gewährleisten kann. Erst Investitionen in eventuelle Verluste werden demzufolge über das in Lohnerwerbsarbeit verdiente Geld subventioniert und eigentlich soll der Weg dann hin sein zu einer selbstversorgung, die Familie als Einheit, aber natürlich die traditionelle Familie. Man kann es echt denken. Und dann ist hier das Versprechen, die Re-Regionalisierung von Wirtschaftskreislaufen beginnt auf dem eigenen Boden irgendwo zwischen eigenem Garten und eigenem Acker. Das sind ja auch so romantische Vorstellungen, wo man sagen kann, wir sind eigentlich auch in der Moderne angekommen. Auch die Frage, wollen wir das? Also wir wären ja jederzeit bereit zu sagen, wir müssen mal über die Industrienahrung nachdenken und wo man wirklich Zucker einsparen kann. Aber wollen wir jetzt wirklich wieder in den Hof zurück? Also manche mögen das wollen, aber für die meisten gilt das nicht. Und vor allen Dingen ist ja auch gerade das Versprechen der Moderne, die Emanzipation aus diesen familiär-höflichen Strukturen. Aber hier wird es alles wieder heraufbeschworen. Nicht allzu romantisch, aber ein bisschen doch schon. Und man kann sich gut vorstellen, dass man damit auch, weil die Leute ja jetzt gerade im Osten Deutschlands den Klimawandel in Form von Waldbränden wunderbar erleben können, dass man glaubt, darüber nochmal jetzt Stimmen zu bekommen, dass man damit Leute für diese Ideologie gewinnen kann. Ich will aber noch einen Text ein bisschen genauer kurz vorstellen. Und zwar heißt der Masse- und Abfall-Überforderungen. Das eigentliche Thema ist nämlich Nahrung dieser Ausgabe. Jetzt diese zehnte Ausgabe habe ich gelesen. Und da ist ein Autor, der mir nichts sagt, August Nagel, der schreibt hier, während die Massengesellschaften im Westen das Resultat wirtschaftlicher Erfolge und technischer Durchbrüche sind, die in der industriellen Produktionsweise mündeten, ist ihre Entstehungsprozesse den Tritt Weltländern, dem unentrinnbaren Sog dieses Sonderwegs geschuldet. Sie sind historisch also nie Akteure in diesem Prozess gewesen, sondern lediglich Spielbälle. Da würde man sagen, ach, das klingt ja fast wie so eine antikolonialistische Position. Der Westen hat die Entwicklungsländer immer unterdrückt und so weiter. Und hier, glaube ich, ist es jetzt wirklich noch mal ganz wichtig zu sagen, Vorsicht nicht, dass man aus postkolonialistischer, also aus so einem postkolonialistischen Standpunkt aus etwas formuliert, was dann plötzlich anschlussfähig wird für neu-rechtes Denken. Es heißt nämlich dann hier die evolutionspsychologische Perspektive, die evolutionäre Populationseigenschaften am Werk sieht, wirft die Frage auf, ob die passiven Teilhaber jeder zu und der Lage sein werden, komplexe Systeme, die es für die Lösung des Müllproblems braucht, aus eigener Kraft selbst zu entwickeln und zu bedienen. Was wird hier also jetzt getan? Wir haben auf der einen Ebene so eine Diagnose, Ausbeutung des Westens, des globalen Südens. Und wir würden erstmal alle sagen, ja, klar. Und jetzt sagt man aber, es gibt da so eine evolutionspsychologische Komponente, die wird zu wenig bedacht. Und evolutionspsychologisch meint natürlich, das ist denen einprogrammiert in die DNA, dass die gar nicht so mit Umwelt sich beschäftigen, wie wir das tun. Das heißt, was hier eigentlich der Anlass für den Text ist, ist, dass man sagt, der Universalismus ist das Problem. Und hier würde ich zunächst mal sagen, wer postkoloniale Theorien vertritt, muss immer von einem universalistischen Standpunkt ausgehen. Denn nur dieser lässt eigentlich zu, dass man tatsächlich alle Menschen als gleich ansieht. Denn sonst kann man sehr schnell in so etwas verfallen, wie dieser Text, der das natürlich nicht zufällig macht, sondern absichtlich, wo dann gesagt wird, dass man eigentlich doch folgendes verstehen muss. Die sind anders wie wir, weil die Evolutionspsychologie sie anders gemacht hat, beziehungsweise sie unterscheiden sich in einem genetischen Sinne. Also das ist, ich glaube, das kann ich so scharf formulieren, eigentlich so ein Update von Rassentheorie, das hier vorgenommen wird. Es geht dann auch darum, die Intelligenzquotienten, die vermeintlichen zu vergleichen der einzelnen Bevölkerungen und zu sagen, warum das so und so ist. Das heißt dann hier Zusammenarbeit zwischen Entwicklern und Unternehmen mit jeweils herausragenden planerischen Fähigkeiten, so wie Intelligenz hat den rapiden Anstieg von Wohlstand und Fortschritt durch Technik ermöglicht. Bodenflächen wurden fruchtbar und ertragreich gemacht. Das gilt für den Westen. Und wir sehen hier schon, wir waren so intelligent. Deshalb haben wir das gemacht. Und hier aber heißt es dann, die kognitiven Merkmale sind von fundamentaler Bedeutung. Die sollte man doch eher wieder in den Blick nehmen, wenn man über Umweltschutz und so weiter spricht. Hier heißt es, der Intelligenzquotient kann diesbezüglich immer noch als hinreichender Indikator gelten. Je klüger, je höher der durchschnittliche IQ in einer Population, desto komplexer Kultur- und Verhaltensregeln und rückwirkend, desto höher die Anforderung an kognitiven Eigenschaften. Derweil zeichnet sich der westlich-europäische Mensch durch relativ hohe Intelligenz aus. Das geht dann irgendwann dahin, dass man dann sagt, dass der Status quo eigentlich nicht einer ist von kapitalistischer Ausbeutung des globalen Südens, sondern man sagt, wir haben diesen Intelligenzvorsprung evolutionsbiologisch, psychologisch. Jetzt muss man mal sehen, ob die anderen den auch haben. Wenn nicht, ist natürlich die Antwort, dann soll jeder schön separiert da bleiben, wo er ist, damit nicht irgendwas miteinander vermischt wird. Und da kommt dann natürlich der Begriff Heimat, der wird dann in dieser Weise aufgeladen. Und das große Feind sind die Ideal-Global-Universalisten, heißt es dann. Und man versucht hier quasi aus so einer antikolonialistischen Perspektive eine Weltordnung zu rechtfertigen, wo keine Flüchtlinge zu uns kommen und wo wir eigentlich sagen müssen, die Menschen sind so unterschiedlich und die werden dann auf ihre oder eine andere Weise schon mit dem Klimawandel auskommen. Und es heißt dann hier, es ist fatal zu glauben, westlichen Humanismus global etablieren zu können. Um Verteilungsmaßnahmen, respektive Entwicklungshilfe, die vorgeblich Wohlstand für alle oder zumindest das Angleichen des Lebensstandards weltweit zum Ziel haben, werden in Teilen Afrikas und Asiens in absehbarer Zeit das genaue Gegenteil bewirken. Das sei alles nur Ideologie, Imperialismus, das Leben. Darum geht es im Einklang mit Gemeinschaft und Natur kann nur aus langsamer Anpassung erwachsen, was mit anderen Worten heißt, wir halten uns daraus. Wir haben uns, weil wir so intelligent sind, so entwickelt. Und dann muss man mal sehen, was mit den anderen passiert. Und da ist die eigentliche ideologische Botschaft, auch in dieser ganzen Zeitschrift, dann zu finden in solchen Aussagen. Und deswegen, glaube ich, muss man hier auch nochmal ganz klar diesen universalistischen Standpunkt klar machen. Auch wenn der Westen sich nicht immer an diesen Universalismus und seine Werte hält, muss man den nochmal ganz klar stark machen. Und nicht jetzt, nur weil Menschenrechte auch vom Westen verletzt werden, man in einem Atemzug die Menschenrechte mit abwickelt. Das ist ja auch etwas, wovor Slavoj Zizek schon gewarnt hat. Den Text hatten wir ja auch schon mal im Salon.
Genau, als die Rechten irgendwann anfingen zu sagen, ne, wir haben gar nichts gegen die anderen Ethnien. Und dann diesen Nachsatz so betonen, die können ja ruhig bleiben, wo sie sind. Da können sie auch machen, was sie wollen. Hauptsache nicht hier und so. Da wurde das immer so ein bisschen kritisch, weil da quasi so eine Verständnis-Ebene vorbereitet wurde, dass dann irgendwer meinte, ach so, ihr habt gar nichts gegen die, ja dann. Ja, ja. Dann wurde ihm einfach nur der Universalismus rausgestrichen. Und das ist natürlich kritisch zu sehen. Mein letzter Text in Kürze. Eine neue Studie zeigt, was Sache ist. Und zwar aufgeschrieben von Atisha Bhatia in der New York Times. Das ist ganz witzig, weil der erschien am 1. August und im Text dann so am Montag erschien In Nature und so weiter. Als wäre da so nichts dabei, dass In Nature mal so ein Text erscheint und so. Also wir sind hier ganz aktuell und es erschien tatsächlich, wahrscheinlich habe ich ihn noch nicht im Original, aber den werde ich mir auf jeden Fall zurechtlegen. Ein Text, der sich die Frage stellt, wie kriegen wir jetzt Menschen aus der Armut? Und wir wissen ja schon, beliebte Antwort ist Bildung. Jeder kann sich aus seiner eigenen Armutslage herausbilden. Das haben wir nun wirklich überall auf der Welt, vor allem hier in Deutschland auch. Und in dieser Studie hat man sich 72 Millionen Menschen auf Facebook angeschaut und mit wem sie befreundet sind. Damit also 84 Prozent der amerikanischen Bevölkerung 25 bis 44 Jahre alt abgedeckt und hat doch Erstaunliches rausgefunden, denn es sind die Freundschaften, die man hat. Wird man arm geboren und möchte ein auskömmliches Leben führen, braucht man früher Freunde, die selber aus anderen Haushalten kommen. Und diese Art Forschung gibt es schon zum Thema Nachbarschaften und so. Wo muss man hinziehen oder was muss man tun, um seine Familie ein bisschen abzugraden, in etwas teure, aber reichere Gegenden ziehen. Dann schleppt sich alles andere nach. Wenn man wartet darauf, dass man zuerst einen tollen Job hat und dann dahin zieht, klappt es meistens nicht. Man muss ein bisschen mutig sein und erst mal ins Defizit reinrennen, weil es teurer ist, da zu wohnen. Aber wenn man dann da ist und seine Kinder da einschult und wie auch immer, zumindest geht das so für Amerika, schien das schon immer so triftig zu sein, dass man auch politische Programme machen wollte. Und jetzt hat man sich hier mal nur die Freundschaften einfach angeschaut, also wer redet mit wem. Und dieses Argument oder die These zu sagen, es sind die Freundschaften, schlagen hier im Vergleich über Methodologie, kann man gleich noch reden, die Qualität der Schule, die Familienstruktur, die Verfügbarkeit von Jobs und die ethnische Zusammensetzung der Community, in der man lebt. Also wenn man irgendwo lebt, wo es reiche Leute gibt oder Wohlhabendere, also man kommt als Arbeiterkind in so ein akademischer Umfeld, dann sollte man auch anfangen mit denen zu spielen. Sich da einfach einladen zu lassen, die dann auch zu sich selber einladen natürlich, aber da Kontakte herzustellen und die Forscher hier nennen das Economic Connectedness, diese Dimension, in der diese Art der Freundschaft und wir kennen ja alle den berühmtesten Texten der Soziologie von, das habe ich selber schon lange nicht mehr studiert, die Weak Ties. Einige wissen jetzt wovon ich rede. Es gab einen Text, der sich fragte, wo kriegt man eigentlich seinen nächsten tollen Job her? Von seinen besten Freunden oder von den Weak Ties? Leuten, die man mal so nebenbei auf der Party kennenlernt. Und klar, die Antwort ist natürlich, es sind die Weak Ties. Es sind nicht unbedingt die engen, lebenslang halten, denn Superfreundschaften, sondern man kennt halt so Leute. Man spielt irgendwie eine Rolle in dem sozialen Umfeld, in dem man ist, man ist in Kontakt und dann kriegt man das zugeschustert und so auf der Ebene sehe ich das hier eigentlich auch maßgeblich.
Also es sind nicht jetzt Freundschaften, um die es geht, die jetzt wahre, tiefe Freundschaften sind, sondern die sagen jetzt eher Netzwerken ist wichtig oder?
Netzwerken ist wichtig und zwar Netzwerken über das eigene ökonomische Milieu hinaus. Man muss da einfach mal mutig sein und vielleicht auch was vorspielen, denn wir wissen ja, die Realität schleppt sich dem Spiel immer nach. Wer einen lange König gespielt hat, ein Spielkönig war aber am Ende wirklich ein König. Nein, so war man es nur bei Anfängen gelesen, aber das stimmt eben damals und heute auch zum Teil. Also der Raj Raj Chetty, C H E T T I ist ein Typ, den sollte man unbedingt folgen. Der ist jetzt seit einer Weile Professor an Harvard, nur ein bisschen älter als wir, aber da extrem drin. Und der sucht sich halt immer solche Fragestellungen raus, wie auch das mit den Nachbarschaften. Und findet dann so eine Operationalisierung, die kann ja hier nochmal jeder selber nachlesen. Man hat es auf 21 Milliarden Facebook-Freundschaften gebracht, die man in den Datensatz reinlud, hat es dann runtergebrochen und solche Sachen wie, also die Daten, die sowieso drin standen, was für Abschlüsse und so weiter, oder auch von welchem Telefon aus füllt man Facebook. Ist es ein iPhone, ist es irgendein Samsung-Ding? Da einfach mal geschaut. Dann nochmal mit den Postleitzahlen abgeglichen. Und Alter, viele demografische Daten, das nochmal mit den eigenen Datenbeständen abgeglichen, die man so hat. Und so, und darüber hat man den ökonomischen Status, das macht man ja in Deutschland auch so, ermittelt. Und sich dann angeschaut, wer hier wie durch seine Biografie kommt. Und dann eben diese Schlüsse gezogen. Das ist dann in dem Falle eine Zusammenarbeit von Harvard und Stanford und der NYU und so weiter und so fort. Und ja, alle sind sehr überrascht und sehr beeindruckt davon. Das ist eben am Ende die Weak Ties mal wieder sind, die losen Freundschaften, die man recht früh so knüpft. Und nicht so sehr der harte Bildungserfolg und so weiter. Ja, ist auch wieder mal ein Plädoyer, mutig in die Welt hineinzugehen, den Umzug tatsächlich zu machen. Auch wenn es erstmal teuer ist, aber dann zahlt es sich aus. Oder eben die Leute auch einfach mal anzusprechen. Geht natürlich nicht nur um die Kinder, sondern hier auch die Eltern. Wenn man im Kindergarten feststellt, ich gehöre nicht unbedingt zur Oberschicht oder so, einfach mal die Leute ansprechen und fragen, ob sich die Kinder trotzdem verabreden können. Also klar, ich kenne das jetzt auch nur aus der Richtung, dass wir so als die deutschen Standardeltern irgendwie im Kindergarten sind. Aber es ist eben 80 Prozent Migrationshintergrund. Und wenn sich die Kinder gut verstehen, spielen die natürlich miteinander. Und man merkt, das ist irgendwie gut für alle, da einfach alle oder wie soll man sagen, nicht die Grenzen zu überschreiten, sondern sie einfach zu ignorieren. Sondern wenn sich die Kinder gut verstehen, verstehen sich halt die Kinder gut. Und dann ist schon klar, dass man irgendwann die erste Grillparty zusammenfeiert und so. Und in der Ansicht ist das mal wieder so ein Text, der uns bei der großen Frage, was bringt den Zusammenhalt gerade hier in Deutschland, wo man wieder sagen kann, es ist am Ende ein ökonomisches Argument, das drinsteckt. Weil hier kann man natürlich auch viel politisch einfach fördern. Es ist immer wieder diese Vereinsarbeit, die Schul-Nachmittagsgestaltung und so weiter und so fort, die hier die Aufstiegschancen ermöglicht. Aber das ist immer ein Rufen im Walde, denn am Ende ist das Schulsystem nur dafür da, die Milieus zu separieren. Das wissen wir ja alle, vor allem hier in Hessen. Aber gut, das ist, wie es ist. Wir könnten es besser machen, weil wir es besser wissen.
Abschließend möchte ich den Salon mit einem Appell, nicht meinem eigenen, sondern dem Appell von Rocco Schamoni. Der hat in der Rolling Stone einen Artikel geschrieben. Und da fängt er erst mal an und sagt da 1999 kam Napster und die wollten die Musikindustrie zerschlagen. So hat das Sean Fanning damals angekündigt. Das ist aber dann nicht gelungen. Die großen Konzerne haben bald verdient. Napster wurde auch aufgekauft. Dann kam die Streaming Plattform. Und das hat sich für die Labels ausgezahlt, für die Künstler jedoch nicht. Die Künstler waren worauf angewiesen, natürlich auf Live-Auftritte. Letztendlich sind die produzierten Platten seit der Digitalisierung für die meisten Künstlerinnen nichts weiter als Werbetools, um Publikum zu den Auftritten zu locken. Aber wenigstens das Live-Business blieb, davon konnten viele in diesem Bereich Arbeitende gut leben. Bis Corona kam, heißt es. Von den Besuchern, die bis 2019 unsere Auftritte besuchten, kommen heute höchstens noch ein Viertel zu den Shows. Wie gesagt, auch hier spreche ich von den kleineren Künstlerinnen. Die Großen betrifft dieser Effekt eher nicht. Aus irgendwelchen Gründen nehmen die User das Ansteckungsrisiko bei Maxen-Konzerten lieber in Kauf. Und wir wissen, die Rolling Stones und so weiter, die haben kein Problem damit, Tickets zu verkaufen. Die könnten hundertmal auftreten und da wäre noch Nachfrage. Aber das ist genau das, was mir auch aus meinem Bekanntenkreis rückgemeldet wird von Leuten, die künstlerisch tätig sind. Und nein, ich rede jetzt hier nicht immer nur von Opernsängern oder so, sondern auch von jemanden, der Indie-Musik macht oder sonst was. Es kommen tatsächlich zu wenige Leute zu den Auftritten. Und Rocco Scharmoni sagt dann auch, das bedeutet dementsprechend auch eine Viertelung der Einnahmen. Ich, der ich als Künstler viele Jahre fast ausschließlich von Tureinnahmen gelebt habe, kann von einem Viertel der üblichen Gagen meinen Kleinbetrieb nicht am Laufen halten. Und ich kenne sehr viele Künstlerinnen, denen es genauso geht und die sich mittlerweile nach anderen Verdienstmöglichkeiten umschauen müssen. So und was ganz wichtig ist, ist, dass er hier mal den Fokus liegt auf die zweite, dritte, vierte Reihe unter den Künstlern und auch all denen, die da im Hintergrund beschäftigt sind. Also das ist ja auch sonst eine Veranstaltungsbranche und all das. Aber dass er wirklich mal den Fokus auf diese Leute legt, ist wichtig. Denn diese Stars, von denen hört man ja auch nichts. Es war ja auch für mich immer noch nicht schlüssig, wie das eigentlich sein kann, dass die Intendanten dieser Theater so. Stumm geblieben sind, dass die auch nicht früher mal gesagt haben, als wir dann geimpft waren und so. Jetzt können wir aber mal wieder voll besetzen. Jetzt können wir auch die Leute mal ohne Maske. Die haben ja zum Teil in Berlin noch länger dran festgehalten. Die Häuser, als sie es eigentlich mussten. Also nun sind mir Intendanten auch immer nur bekannt, also welche, die eher buckeln um. Das sind ja Leute, die bezahlt werden, wie Minister oder Bundeskanzler. Und naja, man kann sich ja auch da wieder fragen, werden die so bezahlt, damit die subversiv sind oder damit sie genau das nicht sind. Also ich würde mal sagen, Intendanten sind eher, okay, mir fallen nur schlimme Worte ein, deswegen lass ich's. Aber es ist interessant. Also der einzige Intendant, der wirklich noch aufgemuckt hat, und das ist ja auch ein Armutszeugnis, weil wir ja nun eigentlich größere, wichtigere Häuser haben, war Dieter Hallerford. Da kann man ja mal drüber nachdenken. Der war ja nicht nur deshalb im Fernsehen, weil er bekannt ist, sondern weil das auch einer war, der hin und wieder mal gesagt hat, nee, Kultur ist auch wichtig. Aber du hast es ja selbst damals im Fernsehpodcast gesagt, Ulrich Mattes ist bei Kulturzeit nur, um darüber zu reden, wie schlimm die Querdenker sind, statt mal die Chance zu nutzen, über die Kulturbranche zu reden. Bei der Berlinale ist Claudia Roth, die ich neben Karl Lauterbach für die schlimmste Besetzung in der Bundesregierung momentan halte, die dann sagt, dieses wunderbare Fest und das Kino und wir erleben die große Leinwand. Ja, aber wann gibt es dann mal weniger Repressionen für die Kinos? Wann fallen dann da Maßnahmen? Ja, also wir müssen ja immer evidenzbasiert und so weiter. Das ist alles Schmerzerei. Deswegen ist es sehr gut, dass Schamoni das noch mal schreibt und mir sagt es dann ausdrücklich. Ich möchte vor dem Artensterben in der Kultur noch einmal eindringlich warnen, denn ehemann sich versieht, verschwinden die kleinen, die speziellen, merkwürdigen, andersartigen, besonderen, dysfunktionalen, unfähigen, sperrigen, unbestechlichen, skeptischen, widerborstigen, nervigen, bescheuerten. Sie verschwinden zuerst, denn sie sind nicht resilient, haben keine großen Reserven angelegt, sind sensible Mimosen, trocknen aus, verdorren, suchen sich Jobs bei der Post oder als Zalandoboten und sind dann für immer aus der Welt. Und das endet dann damit die Kolumne. Drum ihr Zuhausesitzenden. Lasst nicht zu, dass die Merkwürdigen verschwinden. Kommt von den Sofas, kommt aus den Komfortzonen, kommt wieder zu den Auftritten.
Sehr gut. Ich bin natürlich ein bisschen mitschuldig. Gehe zu Iron Maiden und Rammstein. Da schwingt auch so ein Gefühl mit von, da weiß ich, das findet statt und da muss ich nichts klären, sondern da kümmern sich 1000 Leute da mit.
Aber man kann auch sehr viele andere schöne, kleinere Sachen besuchen, die stattfinden. Da muss man auch nicht mithelfen, dass es stattfindet, sondern da kann man auch einfach hin. Und die Leute freuen sich, dass man da ist.
Ich hoffe, das Gefühl kommt dann alsbald zurück.
Genau. Und dann sehen wir uns für die nächste Folge Ende des Monats.
Ganz genau. Texel Edition von meiner Seite aus. Bis dahin. Bis dann. Haut rein, Leute.